how well does the sequel to 2017's it
adapt Stephen King's classic novel while
tying up all the Loose Ends from the
first installment let's roll up our
sleeves wade into the sewers and dig
into the details of how the Saga ends
this is the ending of it chapter 2
explained and before you open the door
labeled very scary the warned spoilers
await you
Stephen King's novel it isn't just the
story of a creepy clown terrorizing some
kids and then returning to do it all
over again when they're adults there's a
whole cosmology to The Saga which
includes a giant god-like turtle that
coughed up the known universe when it
had a tummy ache aside from a few subtle
nods here and there the movies mostly
sidestep the ancient interdimensional
mythology of the book but one element
does show up in it chapter two the true
form of it when he goes to visit the
shokopiwa tribe and takes one of their
Vision granting concoctions Mike learns
that it came to Earth in a meteor strike
that left a crater in Dairy and is made
up of dead lights mostly orange but
sometimes blue spheres of light of
immense power though lights can be seen
in brief moments in the first film it
appears entirely as deadlights as
chapter 2 reaches its Climax and even
after taking on other forms the
deadlights are still visibly powering
the creature becoming increasingly
weaker as the losers literally bring it
down to size
its true form is revealed because the
losers perform the ritual of chud a
ceremony that differs pretty wildly in
the movie from the way it works in the
book the movie's take on the ritual
involves each member of the club burning
a token of his or her childhood and
reciting a chant to make the deadlights
turn dark then trapping the deadlights
inside a pyramid-shaped relic Mike stole
the ritual is the key to defeating it in
the book though it takes two tries 27
years apart but the loser's attempt
essentially fails in the movie at least
at first that's because it's revealed
Mike lied to everyone in an attempt to
Simply bring them all back together the
ritual wasn't successful before when the
Native Americans tried to do it and it
doesn't kill it when the losers try this
time either at least not until they've
gone through the ringer just a little
bit more so they can truly overcome the
fears that feed it
Richie isn't exactly a tough nut to
crack bye Rich what are you afraid of
clowns
token for the ritual of chud is a
literal token from the local arcade and
as is so often the case in the
transition from childhood to adulthood
is fear has morphed into anxiety the
adult Richie throws up twice in it
chapter 2 and threatens to leave Dairy
several times because he just can't
stand the idea of losing what he's
gained as a famous stand-up comedian
Richie spends the first half of chapter
2 mercilessly needling his childhood pal
Eddie and he doesn't hesitate to call
Stanley the weakest of the losers when
he finds out about Stanley killing
himself he can be mean and has a hard
time expressing his real feelings Richie
has to visit the synagogue where Stanley
had a disastrous Bar Mitzvah and more
significantly come to openly care about
the well-being of his closest friend
Eddie whom he finally can admit he loves
to overcome his self-absorption and play
a part in defeating it
for Eddie's part the fear he has to
overcome is also a sort of
self-obsession his hypochondria and fear
of bodily harm are paralyzing they
hamper him from taking action both as a
child and as an adult like when he's
confronted with Stanley's bug-like
severed head we're trying to rescue his
mother from the leper he keeps seeing it
as it isn't until he gives up one of his
gazebos his malapropism for Placebo in
the form of his inhaler for his token
and comes to believe in the monster
killing power of a makeshift spear
fashioned from a metal fence post that
he can work up the courage to mount a
full frontal attack on it weakening the
monster before the rest of the losers
can deal their final psychological blows
Eddie is fatally impaled but in the
service of saving his friends after a
lifetime of being Frozen with fear his
final Act is one of Bravery
even nearly 30 years after his brother
Georgie's death bill is still plagued by
guilt and feelings of responsibility he
finds himself shouting down a storm
drain just like he did in his Youth and
he conveniently gets Georgie's paper
boat back from Pennywise to use as his
token in the ritual he fears not being
able to save the people around him
eventually he tries and fails to save
another young Dairy boy from suffering a
fate similar to Georgie's at the end of
pennywise's teeth it takes a full-on
envisioned confrontation with his
younger self during the final showdown
with it for Bill to come to terms with
what happened and absolve himself of
blame telling himself that he was in
fact a good older brother with that
resolved he can help destroy it and
maybe finally write a decent ending to
his next novel
though Ben has grown from a chubby
bullied kid into a handsome successful
man he still clearly feels ostracized he
notably keeps himself at a remove from
his co-workers at his Architecture Firm
video conferencing in from his massive
empty house meanwhile Beverly is in an
abusive marriage that mirrors her
relationship with her father when she
returns to her childhood home it's
unfamiliar and inhabited by a woman who
turns into a rampaging unclothed monster
nowhere really feels like home to her
after some amnesia-based uncertainty
about who really loved whom on Beverly's
part Beverly and Ben finally find the
linchpins to work through their fears
each other Beverly brings the postcard
with the poem Ben wrote for her to the
ritual of chud and Ben brings the
yearbook page Bev and no one else signed
as Ben is made to think he's being
buried alive in the loser's secret
hideout and Bev finds herself drowning
in blood in the bathroom stall where she
was tormented by bullies they reach out
to each other and break free of its
spell
much like his parents found themselves
trapped as a raging fire killed them
Mike has trapped himself in Dairy while
everyone else left and forgot all about
what happened there in 1989. by the way
he's here it all gets but me I never
left
so yeah
I remember all of them he has appointed
himself the chronicler and expert on all
things it convening with the shakopiwa
in hopes of unleashing ancient secrets
in time for the returning losers to
defeat the creature and it works just
not the way he originally suspected more
than the ritual of chud one little
proverb about living things having to
abide by the rules of the shape they
inhabit ends up being the key to taking
down Pennywise
when Mike remembers that detail he sets
off a chain of events that leads all the
other losers to bring the monster down
to size with their words calling it
little more than a clown their
name-calling shrinks Pennywise down so
small that they can easily pull out his
still beating heart and destroy it Mike
thrives as someone who rallies his
friends as signified by the way he
brings a rock Beverly through at the
Town bullies as his token
a major difference from the book's
ending is that all the movie losers
leave Dairy with the memories of their
encounter with it intact but to
everyone's surprise without the literal
scars from when they cut their hands to
signify their blood Bond at the end of
the first movie the pain is exercised
Bill writes a book that's very similar
to Stephen King's It Ben and Beverly go
on boat excursions together having
finally found true companionship Richie
finishes carving his and Eddie's
initials into a fence finally revealing
how much he cares Mike leaves town at
last and everyone receives a letter from
Stanley written before he killed himself
in the letter Stanley gives a rationale
for his decision to kill himself not to
escape facing down it but to prevent his
friends from dying because he wasn't
sure he could take another round with
the creature he knew if the losers
weren't unified they'd all die when the
adult losers look in a shop window and
see the reflections of their younger
selves Stanley's there I never
on you
the newest adaptation of Stephen King's
It has introduced yet another generation
of kids to their worst nightmares the
1990 TV miniseries scared the Jorts off
of every Millennial with a vcr and four
hours to spare but the 2017 Version
Moves the setting to the late 80s when
milk cartons paraded pictures of missing
children and the New Kids on the Block
were every teen's guiltiest Walkman
pleasure through a wildly entertaining
Fun House of Frights the losers Club
comes together to do what the adults
can't and banish evil but do they really
put an end to their shared enemy let's
take a look at what actually happens at
the end of it the losers Club is strong
there's an undercurrent of teenage
rebellion that informs the story of it
we have a group of misunderstood
underappreciated and in some cases even
abused kids who on their own are
self-described losers with a capital l
bill denbro as a stutter and bears the
guilt of his little brother's
disappearance Beverly Marsh has
developed a wholly undeserved reputation
just as her father asserts his dominion
over her girl good and creepy and
possibly even violent ways the
delightfully foul-mouthed Richie Tozer
is content to spend every second of his
spare time in the arcade Stanley Uris is
constantly picked on for his yamaka
though he can barely recite Hebrew Mike
Hanlon is a homeschooled kid who's still
considered other thanks to his race
Eddie kasbarak is whip smart but
constantly demeaned by his mother and
Ben Hanscom is the new guy who's
pudginess and affinity for the library
makes him an easy Mark for the nastiest
of town bullies by coming together they
ignite a uniquely fearless and fun force
field against the Demonic being that's
plagued their town for years
they're not Invincible unlike other kids
who are perhaps less subject to daily
torture by their peers the losers have
been made to face their fears almost
daily from bullies to oppressive parents
to Lost siblings they've already been
through the worst life can throw at them
so Pennywise despite all its tricks can
only do so much to them especially when
they're United however they do seem to
have a tendency to break apart a little
too soon as we see throughout the movie
Pennywise constantly tries to separate
them to individualize the aggression
since he needs their fears to feed
bye Rich what are you afraid of
clones
that scare tactic doesn't work so well
when they're together but apart they are
completely vulnerable at the end of the
film they agree to reunite if the
occasion calls but they'll go their
separate ways in the meantime which
can't be good news for the next victims
standing alone too they're more likely
to backtrack in their own unique ways
book readers and fans of the miniseries
will know that Stan Uris isn't going to
heal inside or out quite as well as the
others and as for Bevy well
Bev chooses herself kind of apart from
beating us over the head with metaphors
about her reaching adolescence it also
lays on the love triangle element with
Beverly Marsh pretty thick not counting
her grotesque father Beverly is the
apple of not one but two pairs of eyes
January Embers scribe Ben and the
group's de facto leader bill it's Ben's
kiss that summons her from her Pennywise
induced coma but it's Bill's lips she
chooses to smooch before a departure to
her aunts now that she's a self-made
orphan but neither of these fellas are
important enough to keep her around
Dairy Ben and Bill are just roadblocks
to her Retreat from town one she happily
bypasses by the way the bad news is that
anyone familiar with King's riding will
know that her dad isn't the only guy who
will hurt her before it's all said and
done speaking of Mr Marsh parental
plight if you thought Disney movies had
a heavy hand with parents it went hard
on the moms and dads of dairy too
Beverly greases her dad with a toilet
lid Henry Bowers knifes his old man in
the neck just for making him look bad in
front of his friends and and Mike Hanlon
has lost his parents at a horrific fire
even the surviving parents are left a
little worse for wear bill has almost
completely disregarded his parents
sensitivities over their lost son and
Eddie defies his mother's orders and
trashes his Placebo prescriptions part
of the point of this story is to subvert
the whole parent's know-best philosophy
since you know they're largely ignoring
all the missing and murdered children
around town it's basically a big
metaphor for that moment when kids
realize their parents aren't perfect and
begin to think that they can take care
of themselves instead Henry Bowers is
M.I.A on top of Georgie and Henry's fire
spraying henchman Patrick hochstetter
the other Miner who seemingly meets his
maker in the movie is Henry Bowers after
being coaxed into killing his old man by
visions of it his sudden sense of social
Supremacy takes over as he goes on the
offensive against Mike Mike manages to
fight him off and pitches Henry into the
abyss of Pennywise as well which is
immeasurably deep but we shouldn't count
Henry out just yet it's a well-known
Hollywood rule that if a character's
death isn't shown on screen you're
better off assuming it didn't happen on
top of that in the story Bowers plays a
Bonkers part in future events so his
rage will likely linger just as long as
that terrible scar he sliced into Ben's
belly what about the floating kids when
Bill and the rest of the losers come
back together to rescue Beverly from it
they discover her floating midair with
her eyes glazed over
[Music]
let's go
after they spring her from
unconsciousness they learned that she
felt like she was no longer alive while
under the spell of the deadlights after
the losers managed to scare Pennywise
away the rest of the kids that have been
floating in its underground lair start
to drop will they too emerge alive it's
hard to tell either way though it looks
like Georgie won't be coming back to
Captain the SS Georgie again anytime
soon although the other lost children
are potentially being dropped to safety
or at least Absolution for their folks
bills left to grieve over the yellow
raincoat Georgie wore while captaining
his paper boat on the street why he
isn't in the floating kid cloud is a bit
of a mystery so if you listen closely
you can probably hear the justice for
Georgie hashtag being formed right now
it isn't over although the losers do
manage to defeat it at the end of the
movie even they know the fight isn't
over we get a glimpse of it falling
apart but the creature clearly isn't
dead as the news articles Ben has so
carefully assembled indicate its hunger
strikes again every few decades so it's
just a matter of time before it comes
back to claim another slew of victims in
chapter two and when it does everyone in
the losers Club will reunite and dairy
to finish what they started almost all
of them at least
while it might have seemed like the saw
series was game over when the seventh
installment came out in 2010 there was
still a lot of Bloodshed to be had on
the big screen with a little revisionist
history some new and confusing
characters and even more disgusting
traps to behold the eighth installment
of the saw franchise has an even more
complex relationship to the original
story than the other sequels so let's
walk through how exactly jigsaw fits
into the overall puzzle shall we Face
the spoilers or click away now
still dead one of the biggest questions
facing the saw Revival was how the
filmmakers would deal with the demise of
the franchise's primary antagonist John
Kramer AKA jigsaw unlike Jason Voorhees
or Michael Myers jigsaw never had any
Supernatural Powers he was just a
wickedly brilliant guy with an ax to
grind and eventually a terminal case of
cancer so imagine the audience a
surprise when John Kramer shows up to
Stage a new Grizzly test Series in
jigsaw yes it's the same guy who was
laid out called and in the buff on the
autopsy table in saw four and he's
definitely alive when we see him in this
movie but he hasn't magically risen from
the grave instead his newest group trap
series actually takes place 10 years in
the past even though some clever editing
suggests otherwise and while it looks
like there are five victims to bite the
dust there is one guy who secretly walks
away from the whole thing
settling the score in the beginning of
jigsaw's group trap there's one man
who's left behind during the first test
because he's not even awake for it but
it turns out that guy doesn't bite it
after all Logan Nelson who's been
analyzing all the new bodies popping up
with jigsaw puzzle pieces carved out of
them seems like a nice guy throughout
the movie until we learn that he's
actually jigsaw's secret Protege as it
turns out early in his career he
mislabeled Jon's brain scans which may
have made the difference in his
treatment and prognosis but even though
jigsaw is willing to put him into the
group game for his mistake he changes
his mind and decides he doesn't want
Logan to bleed out over a simple
workplace error and decides to train him
instead whether he's ever worked with
any of the other jigsaw minions remains
to be seen a game of his own the new
bodies that are popping up around town
belong to victims of Logan's modern day
copycat game and if each escaped real
punishment for their various crimes
thanks to detective halloran's
questionable ethics one of these people
is Edgar Munson who's shot by police
after claiming to hold the lives of five
others in his hands with remote control
he just so happens to have been the man
who attacked Logan's wife but was let
off easy by Halloran but it's not just
his wife's fate that makes Logan hate
Halloran he also had a girl about his
daughter's age pop up on his autopsy
table who was attacked by a guy who
bribed Halloran so he wants to stop the
bad cop in the worst way possible and
all the people who've perished in this
new round of games are dangerous perps
who Halloran has led off the hook
recently eye on the prize as the body
count climbs Halloran starts to suspect
Logan's jigsaw obsessed assistant
Eleanor and for good reason she's been
recreating jigsaw's most infamous traps
from dark web scoured Blueprints and
seems oddly fascinated by his history
once Logan's old combat buddy detective
hunt catches wind of her Sinister little
Studio he starts to buy into the theory
that Logan and Eleanor are Behind These
fresh homicides however Logan plans some
key evidence that points at Halloran
being responsible for everything and
sets up for a final grudge match with
Halloran himself a big Showdown there
are only three bodies that emerge from
Logan's games which is two fewer than
the casualties of jigsaw's original
scene jigsaw's final two victims bodies
have never been discovered and are still
tucked away in Jill's Farmhouse and
that's exactly where Logan wants to play
in his own final game with Halloran to
make it a total of five players with him
being the sole survivor once again after
planting clues for Eleanor to follow in
the morgue she thinks she's leading him
out to the location with Logan knowing
full well that Halloran will follow once
Halloran tries to NAB them he's quickly
overtaken by Logan who advises Eleanor
to make a break for it and Escape that's
when Logan seizes the chance to put
himself and Halloran in one final
terrible trap the voiceover which has
been dubbed from old jigsaw tapes
suggests that it's John Kramer who's
running things and demanding confessions
from the two and it looks like Logan
fails the test and is taken out first
but once Halloran confesses to having
cost innocent people their lives Logan
reawakens full-on jigsaw Circa the first
saw style and reveals himself to be the
orchestrator of this trap and Logan has
made a game Halloran cannot win an alibi
Eleanor's part in all of this is
interesting to say the At first she
seems to be a perfect distraction for
investigators due to her extracurricular
activities and then she seems to be a
budding love interest for the widower
but in the end Logan says she's just a
pawn meant to provide him an alibi and
support his story that Halloran tried to
kill them but there may be more to her
than meets the eye after all Logan seems
to be doing this solely to punish
Halloran and now that he's brought his
targets to Justice he has a life to get
back to but Eleanor seems just weird
enough to fill the shoes of a jigsaw
emulator she's obviously good at
building traps and has no family to
speak of and even though she doesn't
know she's just worked with jigsaw's
latest Protege she'll probably find out
eventually because Logan can't possibly
explain why halloran's head ends up
looking like an octopus in the end
once upon a time in Romania there were a
thousand and one jump scares that's one
way to describe the nun the fifth entry
in The Conjuring horror film series
based on the case files of paranormal
investigators Ed and Lorraine Warren the
nun is chronologically the first chapter
of The Conjuring story taking audiences
back to 1952 for a few nights of
religious horror the nun is about more
than just a Marilyn Manson look-alike
terrorizing a creepy Church in fact the
movie weaves a web of connections to
every Conjuring Universe movie that came
before it if you were too spooked by the
final showdown to pay that much
attention to the what and the why then
relax we're ready to break down what it
all meant pop on your habits sand your
purple stoles and let's dive into the
ending to the nun
the foreshadowing something is off about
the Abbey of Saint Cardis when the
protagonists first arrived father Burke
and the novice Sister Irene are there
investigating the death of a nun
suspected of taking her own life their
inquiry is aided by a French Canadian
expat named Maurice AKA Frenchy as for
the nuns of the Abbey they seem to be of
no help if they're around at all the
visitors from the Vatican are greeted by
the Mother Superior an inhospitable
hooded host who's basically a nunified
Darth Sidious other than her the place
at first seems suspiciously empty it
turns out that there's a good reason for
that
the god Squad it becomes clear early on
that evil has taken root within the
Abbey an impression that's confirmed
when Irene meets some of the Abbey's
shell-shocked nuns it appears that the
sisters of the Abbey have spent
centuries in constant prayer to keep a
demon from entering the world to a
portal in the Abbey but it's starting to
look like a losing fight as the nun's
final Act kicks in Irene is enlisted to
help pray the devil away she's joined by
an entire Squad of nuns who mean
business all praying like their lives
depend on it it's an awesome moment but
also completely fake as it shortly
revealed that none of those nuns
actually exist
Stop Believing
when Burke and Frenchie reunite with
Irene their presence snaps the sister
back to reality she's not fighting off
the demon nun with a group of other
Catholics instead she's having an
incredibly complex Vision seeing what
appears to be the Last Stand of the
Abbey's now dead residence Irene and
Burke realize that they have been alone
inside the Abbey the entire time saved
for the demon valak and his minions it's
revealed to the audience that the two
nuns from the opening scene were
actually the final two nuns in the Abbey
trying to keep valak from possessing a
human and entering the world Beyond
Saint Carta they realize that the nun
they're investigating didn't die in sin
she died in an act of sacrifice with
this truth revealed it's time for the
final showdown with the big bad nun
just got real
bloody hell after stealing themselves
for the final battle our holy Heroes
descend into the catacombs there Irene
realizes the meaning of a vision she's
been having since childhood a message in
those Visions Mary points the way turns
out to be a set of instructions that are
literally true as she follows a pointing
Virgin Mary statue to a conspicuous fake
wall using the key from the movie's
opening the trio unlocks a hidden door
to a secret passage revealing an ancient
glass Relic containing the blood of
Jesus Christ armed with this powerful
weapon the three go deeper into the
catacombs to confront valak and
hopefully close off the Abbey's gate to
hell things go south when Irene
literally stumbles onto a trap she's
briefly possessed by valik until
Frenchie breaks The Relic and smears the
blood of Christ onto her skin the move
drives the demon away but not without a
fight Irene and valik Tumble into the
water of a flooded room valik holds
Irene underwater until she goes limp
seemingly drowning her and then Irene
spits the in entire container of
Christ's blood into valak's face
grossing the demon out so much that it
decides to go back to hell did I get any
in my
evil persists
when Christ's blood spills into the
water of the flooded room Valic is
overwhelmed by its holy might the demon
dissolves and the Riff is sealed up in
the process as well just like that the
evil has been banished the heroes have
apparently won or so it seems the next
day as Frenchie prepares to transport
Burke and Irene back to the Village he
rubs a hand across his neck revealing a
conspicuous new sign of the inverted
cross on his skin apparently marking him
as being possessed by something evil
that's right it looks like Our Hero's
Victory isn't so certain after all after
all that the demon accomplished its goal
full circle
the movie cuts to 20 years later
revisiting a scene from the very first
Conjuring movie it's revealed that the
lecture the Warrens were seen giving in
that movie about a possessed man named
Maurice was the same Maurice we know
better as Frenchy possessed by valak she
saw something
during the encounter valik touches
Lorraine and triggers within her the
vision of Ed dying that haunted her all
throughout the conjuring 2. turns out
the Visions the Warrens had of the demon
nun in that movie all came from this
encounter with Maurice meaning their
climactic battle was set into motion
before the events of the first movie had
even happened just like that the movie
ties the whole series together drawing a
straight line from the events of Saint
Carta to the Warren's final showdown
with the demented demon making the nun
and the two Conjuring movies a complete
story about a 30-year struggle between
the forces of Good and Evil
[Applause]
American Psycho might have seemed like a
straightforward film about a psychotic
serial killer one who has good hygiene
and announces font types but the third
Act of the movie intentionally unravels
and leaves us guessing about what if
anything actually happens to our
deranged protagonists throughout the
whole film see that's the trouble with
having a delusional Maniac at the center
of the plot his memory of his own
supposed murder spree might not be so
reliable after all like any good film
however there are an abundance of Clues
scattered throughout the movie and
subsequent commentaries might help fans
pass out Patrick Bateman's reality from
his mental fiction so let's take a look
at what really happened at the end of
American Psycho the body count there's
one Surefire facts that we can all agree
upon when it comes to Patrick Bateman
the guy is crazy whether he actually
kills all the people he thinks he does
is up for debates but his status as a
lunatic is not from his obsessive
compulsive Fitness and grooving regimens
to his fixation with cardstock and music
history he's clearly Disturbed but has
he actually killed all those people or
is he just imagining it's all as some
sort of sick Fetish Fantasy part of me
wants to take her out and talk to her be
real nice and sweet and treat her right
and what the other part of him think
what her head would look like on a stick
some believe he's just dreaming up all
those intense Slaughter sessions and
there's some serious evidence to back
that idea up consider the time his ATM
tells him to feed it a stray cat before
he shoots a walk along witness for
interfering at least some part of that
experience is a hallucination and the
fact that he then engages in a shootout
with police that culminates in him
blowing up their cruiser with just as
Gluck was so outlandish even he doesn't
believe it's real and isn't it a little
suspicious that the guy who can rattle
off every shade of ink known to man and
recites an entire encyclopedia on Phil
Collins somehow can't recall his own
kill counts I guess I feel maybe 20
people maybe 40. let's just say that
Bateman takes the concept of the
unreliable narrator to a whole new level
however the convenient Alibi the biggest
mystery in the film revolves around
whether or not Patrick Bateman actually
ever killed his co-worker Paul Allen
played by Jared Leto Paul's death scene
would prove to be one of the most
memorable moments of the movie and
forever change how viewers experienced
Huey Lewis and the News music I think
they're Undisputed masterpieces hip to
be square a song so catchy most people
probably don't listen to the lyrics but
they should Patrick has subsequently
given an extremely convenient Alibi by
the detective investigating Paul's
disappearance that may or may not be the
real deal before the murder Patrick has
shown going to dinner with Paul under
the name Marcus halberstrom another
co-worker Paul has longer mistaken
Patrick for but when questioned the real
Marcus reveals he was at another
location the night of the murder with
Patrick Bateman himself listed as part
of that group so either Patrick has
actually gone to the dinner with Marcus
and his other Pals while dreaming up his
deadly encounter with Paul or he's done
exactly what he thinks he has and his
colleagues mistakenly gift him an alibi
considering how often all those Pearson
and PS vice presidents seem to call each
other by the wrong names The Narrative
definitely seems to be leaning towards
the latter
the cover-up one of the main reasons
we're left to wonder if any of these
murders are real is that every shred of
evidence that might convict him
disappears overnight at the tail end of
his murderous Rampage Patrick has turned
Paul's Swanky apartment into a mini
graveyard for his victims bodies but
when he returns to the scene of the
crime the place is completely clean it
appears that the property owners have
removed all traces of wrongdoing and
painted over the blood-filled closet to
ensure the Red Sea locale's High rental
value and the listing agent's attitude
toward him certainly betrays him
suspicion I want to know what happened
here don't make any trouble please
I suggest you go
then there's the matter of his lawyer
who made feverishly confessed to via
voicemail at first Harold Khan's
literally laughs off his message calls
him by the name Davis and says Patrick
Bateman is a sorry subject choice for
such a joke because he's too dorky to
actually commit murder that was you
wasn't it yeah natural Bateman Gilling
Allen in the escort girls that's
fabulous that's rich but then when
Patrick makes it clear he's not joking
his attorney claims that there's no way
he could have killed Paul Allen because
I had dinner with Paul Allen twice in
London
just 10 days ago no you
could this man who has caught his own
client by the wrong name twice have
simply mistaken Paul Allen with someone
else too sure which is why it takes some
explanation from on high to really
understand what was meant by these
ambiguous scenes let's hear from the
folks who made this thing the voice of
authority director Mary Haron has since
revealed that she never intended for
audiences to believe Patrick was
innocent is everyone is people keep
coming out of this films thinking that
it's all a dream and I never intended it
she went on to explain that the last
scene wasn't meant to make it seem like
Patrick Bateman can't separate his
imagination from reality but rather that
khans on the rest are the ones who are
really confused not everything was real
of course screenwriter Guinevere Turner
has said that the turning point in
Patrick's psychosis takes place when he
gets absorbed in his own reflection
while sleeping with two prostitutes she
told Yahoo movies in real life they
probably weren't as attractive as they
are and it wasn't all as Penthouse
Letters as it is in other words Patrick
Bateman might have embellished a few of
the more outrageous details fails but he
really was hurting people all the while
what really matters however is how
others around him react according to
author Brett Easton Ellis who pends the
novel upon which the film was based
American Psycho is meant to be a
statement on male Hedonism in the 80s
Wall Street circuit the whole reason
Bateman gets away with the murder of
Paul Allen is that everyone in Patrick's
Professional Circle is so self-absorbed
that they can't even keep each other's
identities straight their attention is
firmly focused on acquiring material
wealth and their biggest problems
revolve around getting dinner
reservations at the fanciest restaurant
in town even the owners of Allen's
apartment are willing to dispose of a
serial Killer's evidence to ensure
maximum profit in the end there are no
redeeming qualities about Bateman or
anyone he knows for that matter and even
when he tries to come clean about what
he's done the people around him are too
wrapped up in their own interests to
care and even after admitting this
there is no catharsis My Punishment
continues to elude me
and I gain no deeper knowledge of myself
Jordan peels gets out had a lot to say
but us has arguably twice as ambitious
doubling down on both the horror and the
social commentary but if you didn't
quite catch what the movie was going for
then it might also be a frustrating
watch there's a lot going on beneath the
surface of this movie and we mean that
literally
the premise of us revolves around
Sinister slasher movie doppelgangers who
show a part of nowhere with apparently
murderous motives is supposedly focuses
on one family the Wilsons being attacked
in a home invasion by brutal copies of
themselves but the third act reveals
that it's not just the Wilsons having
this strange experience it's the entire
United States of America with an
unfathomably huge amount of doubles
being led by a woman named red the
shadow version of Lupita nyongos
Adelaide that's the first twist the
movie throws at you but the second big
twist to teased out slowly is that the
ADI the audience has been following the
whole movie isn't the original Adelaide
it's a double who switched places with
her at a young age during the movie's
opening flashback scene grown-up ADI is
haunted by an experience from her youth
when she wandered into a boardwalk
Funhouse and saw a Sinister vision of
herself but the movie leaves out crucial
information of what happened during that
encounter apparently reflecting the fact
that Addie herself is suppressed what
happened as she recalls she wandered
into the attraction found herself and
then shortly returned to a panicking
parents but as the final frames of the
movie Reveal a whole lot of
consequential stuff happened during that
brief period like the fact that the
original ADI never came back in the
movie's final moments ADI realizes or
perhaps just finally admits to herself
that she is the double From The
Underground who strangled the original
ADI and took a place leaving the
original ADI Shackled down below to
begin a new life as read one big clue
that this is what happened is that red
is the only one of the doubles I can
talk everyone else only emits inhuman
Grunts and moans with red speaking in a
raspy damaged voice turns out this comes
from the damage her double did to her
throat when she strangled her when the
double entered the real world she still
didn't know how to speak leaving her
parents baffled at their daughter's
sudden apparently trauma-induced
muteness Addie spends the First Act
sporting a serious sense of dread but
the twist changes our perception of what
that dread is all about mod has played
somewhat Ambiguously it seems like the
adult ADI truly does not know at the
beginning of the movie where she really
came from but she knows something is
wrong and that a reckoning is coming I
think
it means
closer
the first thing most people probably did
when they got home from seeing us was
Google the phrase Jeremiah 11 11 which
turns up in the film multiple times
though translations differ the sentiment
of that Bible passage is pretty clear
it's payback time the international
standard version of the passage
translates into I'm about to bring
disaster on them from which they won't
be able to escape they'll cry out to me
but I won't listen to them it's clear
what's being set up here and Us Versus
Them conflict between the oppressed
tethered underclass and the ignorant
privileged surface dwellers led by Red
the original Adelaide one big thing the
red twist does is completely
recontextualize who the viewers should
be rooting for in the story red still
became a bad person but realizing why
she's so thirsty for Revenge again study
makes her a sympathetic villain and vice
versa one person who clearly picks up on
Addy's other wealthy nature is her son
Jason who witnesses her growling and
snarling her way through several fights
in the movie while he doesn't say
anything about it he comes to
increasingly regard his mother with
apprehension even Terror realizing that
the woman he thought he knew may not be
the one she said she is at the end of
the movie as Addie realizes her true
nature while Jason watches Jason pulls
his mask down on his head to which Addie
Smiles in response putting on a mask of
her own at his true nature as a tethered
person also comes into play drawing some
of her more inexplicable actions like
getting out of the car to watch the Zora
double die or refusing to strike the
double of Jason when he confronts them
near a burning car her actions don't
seem to make sense until you understand
what she's realizing these people are
her people and maybe she doesn't want to
hurt them after all
the question of who created the tether
doesn't get answered and that's probably
for the best it's also what Jordan Peele
intended with many of the movie
specifics being intentionally open to
interpretation think of it less like a
puzzle and more like an inkblot I want
to leave some runway for people to
explore what it means to them while the
viewer might think that Addie's visit to
the Mirror Maze is what triggered the
creation of her double the ending
demonstrates that the doubles already
existed on the ground long before she
arrived how it's unknown it's designed
to be that way and it's really not
important no answer on this Earth would
be as satisfying as the mystery feels
the most obvious explanation is that the
doubles come from a secret government
experiment an unfathomably massive
cloning project of some sort that copied
every American's body while failing to
replicate the soul but since the scale
of such an operation seems impossible
for humans to accomplish it's hard to
take this explanation at face value in a
logistical sense nothing can explain how
the doubles are created much less how
they got 300 million pairs of scissors
Freddy Krueger gloves and red jump
concerts the fact is the real villains
of the movie are the people who set up
this deranged experiment before
abandoning its subjects but whoever
these people are they never actually
appear without the ability to identify
confront and fight back against their
real oppressors the characters instead
to tear each other apart and that sounds
like a big fat metaphor for American
society to us we are Our Own Worst Enemy
foot and peel is described us as being
about the fear of the other and the
self-destructive tendencies that fear
can cultivate with this framework in
mind the tether can represent a lot of
different groups maybe it's all the
people that American society has
condemned over the centuries victims of
the slave trade mass incarceration
racism or a predatory cluster void they
represent the Forgotten Americans who
fall through the white holes and the
country's social safety nets the people
we abandon the Striking Final Shots of
the movie show these people stretched
across the continent in a human chain
hand in hand beneath the blue sky and
the Sun for so long they suffered living
only a shadow of a good life that their
doubles enjoyed not anymore though it
took a lot of killing to get topside but
considering the suffering they went
through it's almost hard to blame them
for making the effort remember what red
told Adelaide they're humans too you
know just like us
or Hit Factory Blum House has returned
to theaters with a mind-bending sequel
to happy death day and this time
everything's different while the
space-time twisting tale may be a little
headier than its predecessor there's no
reason to be caught out of the loop
let's break down the ending of happy
death day to you the first happy death
day follows tree geldman's Journey from
a stuck up sorority mean girl to a
sympathetic take charge Survivor it was
a satisfying character Arc told in
Charming fashion feeling like Groundhog
Day by way of Friday the 13th hey uh you
know I don't think you should be taking
that many I mean you could you could die
if only
in the first movie the mechanism that
causes tree to go into a day repeating
time Loop is never revealed appearing
simply as a mystical phenomenon that
serves to drive the story but director
Christopher Landon has long promised
that an explanation for the loop is
hidden in the movie Set up in advance to
be explored in the sequel as he claimed
in an interview with Insider the whole
idea for my sequel is actually already
in this movie it's hiding in plain sight
many viewers took the director's lead
concocting their own theories about the
Loop's Origins the movie's emphasis on
tree's deceased mother as well as their
long-lost tradition of blowing out
birthday candles together gave rise to
the hypothesis that tree's mom had
something to do with the loot with her
spirit somehow manipulating time from
Beyond the Grave to keep her daughters
safe but happy death day to you firmly
debunks these theories revealing a
source for the phenomenon that's more
science fictiony in nature than anyone
saw coming in what feels like a wild
departure from the original happy death
day to you reveals that tree's time
twisting Journey was caused by a literal
time machine located in a science lab on
the Bayfield University campus the
device is partially the invention of
Carter's roommate Ryan the office Goober
from the first movie with a tendency of
barging in every time tree wakes up
while the first movie paints Ryan as
awkward and sex-obsessed the sequel
Reveals His hidden depths as well as an
intellect that would do good by Doc
Brown himself the opening act of the
sequel reveal feels that Ryan is in the
process of developing the time machine
with a team of fellow student scientists
named Samar and Sarah while they haven't
perfected the device just yet and who
knows how they're funding this thing the
team soon discovers that it's fully
capable of disturbing the fabric of
space-time the time Loops turn out to be
an unintentional side effect of their
machine meaning that of all people it
was actually Ryan who was responsible
for tree's most bogus birthday Journey
she's not happy about it the lab
students who developed the machine call
it the Sisyphus Quantum cooling reactor
or [ __ ] for short the name is an on the
nose reference to the Greek legend of
Sisyphus a man punished by the gods to
spend each day rolling a boulder up a
hill never quite reaching the top as
viewers are the first happy that they
know it's a trial that tree can
definitely relate to
the introduction of [ __ ] marks a clear
pivot from the first movie's horror
trapping stored straight up science
fiction but happy death day to you also
leans into a more romantic angle than
its acerbic slasher predecessor becoming
more of a Sci-Fi rom-com than the scream
like original when the machine is
activated to kick off the movie's second
act it sends tree into a parallel
dimension in which her relationships
with the people around her are ever so
slightly askewed the changes are small
but significant forcing tree to
reevaluate her own life and what she
wants out of it while the first
Dimensions Carter is single until he
meets tree the second dimension version
is happily dating Danielle a rival of
trees and the Alpha Dog of her sorority
in tree's World her mother has been dead
for the last three years but in the
second world that she ends up in her
mother is still alive as a result of
these change-ups the tension in the
story this time around isn't so much
will tree survive as it is will love
prevail with the Babyface villains
Killing Spree being left somewhat in the
background in the sequel tree's biggest
challenge is figuring out whether she
wants to live in a reality with a
resurrected mother or go back to her
original Dimension where she just begun
what could end up being a loving
long-term relationship with Carter much
like scream cabin in the woods and other
winking works of metafiction the
characters and happy death day to you
are aware of the fact that they seem to
be living through the plot of a movie in
this case parallels are drawn with Back
to the Future Part Two The time-hopping
Adventure sequel from 1989. that movie
Saw Marty McFly not just revisiting the
past but also the plot of the previous
movie intersecting with the older
narrative in new and unexpected ways on
top of the Back to the Future sequel
being surprisingly relevant to the
movie's plot happy death day to you also
Sports a few references to the Sci-Fi
series examples of these tips of the
hats include a wood chipper from Biff's
tree removal that tree cheerfully tosses
herself into at the end of one loop as
well as the painful speed of 88 miles an
hour she attains during one desperate
death behind the wheel when this baby
hits 88 miles per hour
you're gonna see some serious while it's
not necessarily hard to follow happy
death day to you clearly doesn't want
the audience to linger too much on the
how of its storytelling breezing through
plot points faster than you can say wait
what after being shot through space-time
to relive her birthday Loop in a whole
other dimension tree is faced with two
tasks the first goal is to return to her
own reality a course of action which she
can't immediately decide if she wants to
take considering that her mother is
still alive in this new world but her
second goal of stopping the time Loop is
something she has to achieve no matter
what regardless of which reality she
decides to stay in the problem is that
[ __ ] is a work in progress a powerful
machine that neither Ryan nor his lab
mates yet entirely understand in order
to get it under their control they need
to do more research lots of research
each time the loop resets they lose
their progress with the memories of
everyone but tree being reset to the
state they were in when the loop started
as a result trees forced to become the
team's institutional memory keeping
track of the complex quantum mechanics
that make the machine work it's a tall
task and a battle of inches with the
team only making progress thanks to tree
resetting the loop by offing herself
elaborately and hilariously over and
over again
complicating all this Quantum confusion
is the inconvenient fact that just like
the first movie there's a killer on the
loose in the first film The Babyface
masked killer is portrayed by two
characters three sorority sister Lori
and a serial killer named John tombs who
Laurie sets up to frame for tree's death
in the first movie's reality Lori was
motivated to kill tree out of jealousy
due to her romantic relationship with
Gregory Butler a married professor and
medical doctor whom Lori wanted the doe
eyed nice girl was a most unexpected
villain making for a satisfying twist
when she's actually innocent in the
second world so who's killing people and
happy death day to you the sequel
features three characters wielding
knives behind the baby mask for the most
part the killings in the second world
are being committed by Dr Butler himself
as well as shockingly his wife Stephanie
who seems to have been driven insane by
Gregory's infidelity while the two at
first appeared to be in cahoots with
each other that doesn't really hold up
after Gregory decides to shoot Stephanie
during the movie's climax in this
reality they are apparently both just
crazy and seem to totally deserve each
other what a shame that it didn't work
out
the third killer only appears in the
movie's First Act while Ryan is
experiencing his own time loop on
September 19th and the reveal is a weird
one
of the weirdest threads and happy death
day to you is the idea that the Babyface
killer pursuing Ryan in the movie's
opening is actually another version of
himself invading the first Ryan's
reality to stop him from causing the
time Loops in the first place it's a
tantalizing reveal to kick off the
movie's second act promising
doppelgangers evil twins and
intertwining timelines that the movie
just doesn't follow up on if you thought
you missed something well you didn't
despite that lack of a firm explanation
the second Ryan seems to be from the
future possessing knowledge about the
time Loops effects that no one Beyond
tree should really have yet as much as
it seems like this plot development
could be a setup for tree zone
doppelganger being the killer in
dimension two that's not the case in
fact tree is explicitly told there
aren't two of her in dimension two when
tree goes to the second Universe She
replaces herself in it despite the
precedent set by a second Ryan an
alternate version of tree never shows up
so how did Ryan end up with two copies
of himself running around there are many
possibilities but in the movie itself
there are no answers happy death day to
you seems to end on a cheerful note of
tree returning to her own reality the
time Loop being broken and all of her
hard-earned progress in life restored
but the world in the movie gets blown
wide open in an out of the left field
mid-credit sequence which takes the
Sci-Fi aspects of the sequel and goes
all the way with him the scene begins
with tree and her co-conspirators doing
campus us cleanup is punishment for
their reality shattering lab work the
destructive effects of which The Faculty
can only begin to imagine but just
because the dean is in the dark about
the time machine's capabilities doesn't
mean everyone is out of nowhere the
students are approached by a fleet of
dark-suited Special Agent types from
DARPA a real-life Federal research
agency the agents promptly transport the
students to their headquarters where
they've set up the confiscated [ __ ]
machine it's revealed that the agency
wants to do their own research with the
machine but they need the students
know-how in order to make it work they
also need a suitable test subject for a
new time Loop of their own creation as
Carter points out what they're proposing
is a sadistic experience that no one
deserves to be put through except maybe
Danielle who ends the movie waking up
and screaming apparently caught in her
own time Loop the ending of happy death
day to you marks a wild shift in tone
that the sequel has spent its whole
runtime building to setting up a third
movie in a way few could have
anticipated we're not just Theory
crafting either writer director Chris
Landon and producer Jason Blum have
already said they intend to make a third
movie with the likelihood of it
happening all depending on the box
office performance of happy death day to
you
as Blum explained in an interview with
cinepop the genre twisting nature of 2u
is totally intentional Blum said I've
never seen a franchise where one movie
is a certain genre and the next movie is
a different genre and that's certainly
the case with happy death day and happy
death day to you and hopefully if we
make a third one it'll be a different
Third Kind of genre
while horror fans may be disappointed in
the series leaving behind its slasher
Roots it's hard not to be interested in
where this story could go Landon teased
a potential third movie by saying he has
what feels like quote a really Bonkers
fun idea if audiences turn out for the
weirdness of happy death day to you then
we might get the chance to see the
series Go full bore nutso in the next
and final chapter is it possible that
this movie was designed with loose ends
that could be tied up later from the
mid-credits Shocker to the mysterious
second Ryan it certainly seems that way
and if the three quote gets its green
light we can't wait to see where the
story goes
an uncertain future Supernatural
suggestions and a 40-year long story arc
coming to a close there's a lot to
unpack and Halloween ends including the
way it actually ends at the start of
Halloween ends Jamie Lee Curtis's Lori
Strode is doing her best to move on with
her life no longer hidden away from the
world Laurie starts writing a book about
her experiences with Michael Myers while
living with her granddaughter Allison
played by Andy matichick however Lori
still senses there's Darkness infecting
Haddonfield Illinois before long all of
her old fear paranoia and Readiness to
fight start to re-emerge but by the end
of the film Lori seems to have finally
been able to put those things to rest at
least for the most part she's killed her
Boogeyman destroyed his body and gone
back to work on her book she even lets
Alison leave Haddonfield to start a new
life Halloween ends suggests that
haddonfield's most determined Survivor
has undergone a rebirth of sorts but
that she's still a little haunted
serving as a reminder that Laurie will
never stop looking over her shoulder
it's revealed that Lori has Michael's
mask which is sitting on a table in her
office
Allison Nelson grew up with the paranoid
Specter of her grandmother looming over
her while Lori tried her best to offer
love and protection it's clear that
Allison's view of the world has been
informed by her upbringing like Lori
Allison is trying to move on from the
darkness of haddonfield's past but she
now has her own inner Darkness to
contend with not only is Alison
wrestling with the deaths of her parents
at Michael's hands in Halloween and
Halloween kills she's also forced to
overcome her romantic relationship with
Corey Cunningham the new local Boogeyman
at first Alison is unwilling to believe
her grandmother's claim that she's
heading down a very dark path with Corey
however she ultimately realizes that
Lori was right to warn her and a brand
new serial killer was hiding in plain
sight but the solution when all the
fighting is over and both Michael and
Corey are dead isn't to keep hiding or
to lock herself away in Haddonfield like
her grandmother once did instead Alison
leaves her hometown behind to start
fresh somewhere else while she seems
hopeful it's clear that Allison is all
too aware of the true levels of the
world and well equipped to take care of
herself
following the losses at the end of
Halloween kills the pool of Michael
Myers survivors has shrunk considerably
one major player who stuck around for
Halloween ends alongside Lori and
Allison is Lindsay Wallace played by
Kyle Richards of course in 1978's
Halloween Lindsay was Annie brackett's
babysitting charge her babysitter Andy
bracket was executed that night Lindsay
managed to hide from Michael in
Halloween kills and survive four years
later Lindsay seems to have a pretty
good life she's running a local bar
throwing festive Halloween parties for
the locals and even growing closer to
Lori and Allison but when violence
starts to creep back into Haddonfield
Lindsay is swept up in the Michael Myers
hysteria once again however Richard's
character doesn't play as big a part in
Halloween ends and she doesn't face the
same level of violence that follows
Laurie and Allison by the end of the
film Lindsay stands as one of only a
handful of survivors of the original
1978 Massacre alongside Lori as far as
we can tell it seems like she'll remain
in heaven field where she'll be an
important part of the town's future
particularly since she knows how to move
on from tragedy will Patton's Deputy
Frank Hawkins was one of the men who
arrested Michael Myers on Halloween
night in 1978. in Halloween kills we
learned that Frank and Lori once had a
strong flirtation that could have turned
into something more if they were both so
damaged and reluctant I always like to
in Halloween ends Frank and Lori run
into each other in a grocery store and
it seems like it might finally be the
right time to pick up where they left
off at the end of the film following
Lori's gruesome battle with Michael
Myers Frank stops by Lori's House the
pairs sit together on her front steps
and it's suggested that Laurie might
finally be ready to take a chance on
romance now that her boogeyman is behind
her while it's unclear whether or not
they'll actually get together viewers
are left with a sense of hope for a
potential shared future
Halloween ends is based around the story
of Corey Cunningham a local Haddonfield
kid whose world was shattered on
Halloween night in 2019. Corey was
responsible for the death of a child he
was babysitting making him a town Pariah
and leaving him with a lifetime of Lost
Dreams however Corey's guilt is
eventually eclipsed by his desire to
understand his own darkness and go
deeper into it something he's able to do
when he crosses paths with Michael Myers
in a sewer Dream by the end of the film
Corey has essentially proclaimed himself
the new Haddonfield Boogeyman he even
goes so far as to steal and wear
Michael's mask in an attempt to get
revenge on all the people who have
wronged him of course Lori is smarter
than Corey and manages to stop him in
his tracks after leaving a path of
bodies in his wake Corey becomes
integral to haddonfield's tragic Legacy
but for now at least it's unclear
whether he is a new Boogeyman or just a
footnote in the story of Michael Myers
Haddonfield is a town that has been
rocked by an absurd amount of tragedy
over the course of 40 years and it's
taken a toll even with Michael Myers
gone the town continues to suffer what
feels like an ongoing series of
accidents deaths suicide and other
tragedies there's a darkness in
Haddonfield which Lori Witnesses even
when she does something as benign as
going to the grocery store it's also
revealed that some of Michael's
survivors and their families blame her
for provoking the killer to more
violence Michael's death at the end of
the film and the ceremonial crushing of
his body at the junkyard temporarily
puts an end to this Darkness but viewers
are left with more questions about the
future of Haddonfield such as will the
town ever truly be free of the Specter
of evil will more people like Corey
Cunningham rise up to take Michael's
place or as haddenfield finally able to
live in a world of Safety and Security
once again it's an understatement to say
that the town's been through a lot and
the road to any sort of recovery is
bound to be very long
though Michael has seemingly died in
other Halloween films none of them quite
matched the death he was given in
Halloween ends after being pinned to a
table by Lori and Allison Michael was
bled to death through several cuts to
key arteries along his body but as
Allison astutely noted Michael Myers
still wasn't quite dead enough with the
support of local law enforcement and
much of the Town Lori and Allison took
Michael's body to the nearby junkyard
there they placed him in a grinder and
crushed him to pieces while his body has
destroyed everyone is left wondering
whether Michael Myers can ever really be
killed in Halloween kills Lori theorized
that Michael Myers seemed to possess a
superhuman ability when it came to
killing and cheating death the more he
kills the more he transcends into
something else Halloween ends seemingly
demonstrates Lori's theory in one
particular scene Michael kills Allison's
ex-boyfriend and his body seems to
almost immediately recover some of its
strengths but were never told where
Michael's immense strength comes from or
whether someone else can actually access
it while Corey seems to believe that he
can take over from Michael and perhaps
acquire some of that power his fast
demise suggests otherwise Michael Myers
is dead the ending of Halloween ends
makes that clear by showing us his
corpse then crushing that corpse in a
brutal piece of junkyard Machinery the
film is intent on making sure that this
Michael Myers timeline is complete and
at Lori strode's fighting Days Are Over
except not all of Michael is really gone
at least not the version of Michael that
emerged when he pulled on his mask and
became the shape the final shot of the
film reveals that the mask battered and
burned is still present in Lori's house
as a dark souvenir of her Victory Lori
probably wanted to keep the horrifying
object because she didn't want
collectors or copycats to get their
hands on it it's also worth noting that
she could have destroyed the mask but
she didn't Lori's decision to save the a
mask raises a number of intriguing
questions for one we're left wondering
if the mask might hold power over Lori
now that it's in her possession Michael
never wanted to remove the mask and he
would stop whatever he was doing to pull
it back down if someone tried to take it
from him plus Michael's apparent
Transcendent abilities while wearing the
mask suggests that it's more than just a
face covering if so Lori may have made a
terrible mistake in keeping the mask as
a trophy
Haddonfield is a relatively small town
that's been rocked by some serious
tragedies Through The Years in fact
Corey Cunningham is the second major
mass murderer to come out of the town in
40 years and his Killing Spree is
inextricably linked to the devastation
caused by Michael Myers in 2018's
Halloween a pair of True Crime
podcasters came to town with a specific
focus on the town's 1978 tragedy proving
that there was widespread interest in
the case and in Halloween ends Laurie
Strode completes her Memoir about
Michael Myers and it seems likely that
the book will throw haddenfield into the
national Spotlight once again as
haddenfield looks to a future without
the serial killer will Lori Embark upon
a book tour to promote her work will the
town's various True Crime stops become
tourist destinations basically following
Corey's murder spree and the death of
Michael Myers haddonfield's profile is
on the rise even if the trilogy has come
to an end
Halloween ends represents an interesting
Benchmark in the history of the
Halloween franchise it's not the first
film that has attempted to kill off
Michael Myers for instance Michael and
Dr Sam Loomis were blown to Smithereens
in 1981's Halloween 2 and they both
managed to return in the fourth film in
1998 Lori decapitated Michael with a
fire ax in Halloween H2O however this
version of events was retconned in
2002's follow-up Halloween resurrection
Michael's deaths didn't seem as final
and definitive in those earlier films as
the one in Halloween ends but may he
never
have a rest in peace whether Michael's
dead or not fans clearly still have an
appetite for the Halloween series but as
for where the franchise might go next is
currently unclear while Jamie Lee Curtis
seems to be well and truly done with
playing Lori Strode there's a
possibility that the series could be
rebooted in the future by a different
Studio blumhouse no longer has the
rights to the franchise having agreed to
deliver only three films but producer
Jason Blum and original Creator John
Carpenter have both suggested that as
long as Halloween films make money
someone will want to make more of them
Halloween could also live on without
Michael 1982's Halloween 3 season of The
Witch which doesn't feature the serial
killer has developed a cult following in
the years since its release in fact some
fans have even wondered if new films in
the franchise could actually revisit the
Season of the Witch timeline or take
some other radically new approach
regardless of what happens next it's
clear that the Halloween franchise is
never really over as Michael Myers
always comes back
a quiet place part 2 picks up right
where the first sleeves off with her
Farmhouse and ruins the surviving habits
head out into the wider World
discovering that not everyone is taken
to the apocalypse as gracefully as they
have let's break down the ending of a
quiet place part two writer director and
Star John Krasinski calls the quiet
place films a love letter to his
children and when a quiet place part 2
ends it's easy to see why well the first
movie is all about the sacrifices
parents make to keep their children safe
the second sees the Abbott kids step up
and become Heroes with both Reagan and
Marcus managing to defeat the death
angel in both cases the kids are
protecting the adults around them
reversing the roles of the previous film
when they needed their parents
protection both of their victories also
show how their experiences and harsh
post-apocalyptic world have changed them
and not necessarily for the better most
importantly though these are two moments
of huge personal growth for Marcus who
is somehow even more anxious in a quiet
place part 2 than he was in the first
movie this killing of a death angel is
when he finally overcomes his fears and
stands up for himself for Reagan it
marks the end of her Quest she's done
her part to save the world honoring her
father's memory in the process the most
important character in a quiet place
part 2 may be one who's already dead Lee
Abbott played by Krasinski sacrificed
himself in order to save his family in
the first movie and his legacy looms
large over the sequel Lee taught Marcus
the skills the boy uses to survive the
movie's climax Reagan embarked on her
journey to find the radio tower because
she says it's what Lee would have done
that's why the opening flashback in a
quiet place part 2 is more than an
excuse to give Krasinski some screen
time sure it's fun to see how everything
started and the opening invasion is full
of exciting set pieces it's not just fan
service though Lee is Central to both
Reagan and Marcus's Arc so having him
appear in the beginning makes the ending
hit a lot harder while the first movie
showed that Lee could be obsessive and
hard-headed his portrayal in part 2 is
overwhelmingly positive he's a good
father a nice neighbor and a well-liked
member of the community showing up late
to a little league game seems to be his
only flaw in this case that's okay this
time Reagan Marcus and Evelyn are
dealing with Lee's memory not the actual
man it only makes sense that we see an
idealized version 2. Lee is also Central
to the story of Emmett the Abbott's
former neighbor who was holed up in the
old steel mill Emmett is everything that
Lee isn't instead of sacrificing himself
to save his family Emmett watched his
wife and children die while the abbots
tried to make life on the farm feel as
normal as possible Emmett trades comfort
for survival Lee sought out other
survivors Emmett argues that anyone
who's still alive isn't to be trusted I
don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
the contrast between Lee and Emmett
becomes even more pronounced when Emmett
reluctantly agrees to accompany Reagan
on her trip to the radio tower
essentially becoming a surrogate Father
Figure to the young girl despite his
Gruff then at times paranoid exterior
Emmett is a good man and the journey
changes him he forges a real bond with
Reagan even using the limited amount of
sign language he knows to protect her
from danger once he and Reagan reach the
island Emmett discovers that much to his
surprise good people can still thrive in
this world when the monster attacks
Emmett pulls moves straight from Lee's
Playbook putting himself In Harm's Way
to save others he draws the monster's
attention away from the community by
driving the truck and puts himself In
Harm's Way to protect Reagan at the
radio station Emmett will never take
Lee's place but by the end of the film
he's beginning to follow his old
friend's example and the world is better
off for it a quiet place part 2 expands
on the world of the first movie by
explaining the monster's Origins yes
they're from space and also showing how
different communities have reacted to
the apocalypse beyond the Abbott's Farm
it's such an inspired sequel the world
expands in this one because they have to
to venture out for Krasinski who wrote
the screenplay for a quiet place part 2
on his own this presents a conundrum
despite the wide open cornfields and
Airy feel of the Abbott's Homestead the
first Quiet Place movie really takes
after films like alien and John
Carpenter's The Thing which trapped
their heroes in a confined space with a
deadly paranoia-inducing monster going
outside the farm threatens to upend that
balance robbing the sequel of everything
that makes the franchise special
krasinski's solution to this problem is
clever while the world gets larger in a
quiet place part 2 the action itself
moves into increasingly small spaces the
opening flashback consumes an entire
town the first steps in the Abbott's
Journey take them into the Wilderness
from there they moved to the steel mill
and then a small bunker inside by the
time Marcus and Evelyn reach the movie's
climax they're trapped in a cramped to
Vault similarly Reagan and Emmett go
from upstate New York to a remote
isolated island and end up making their
final stand in a tiny radio station in
this way Krasinski ratchets up the
claustrophobic tension that defined the
first movie even while broadening the
series's mythology at the same time a
quiet place part 2 plays on the confined
atmosphere of the first movie in another
way too in part two all of the
characters are trapped sometimes
literally Marcus steps on an actual bear
trap Emmett has a rope tied around his
neck restricting his movement Reagan
ends up cornered in an old train an
entire Community is stuck on an island
with nowhere to run when a monster
attacks baby Abbott is kept in a box and
Marcus locks himself in the Vault Under
the steel plant but the characters are
mentally trapped too Marcus is dominated
by a spear Emmett is haunted by his
inability to save his family Reagan's
sense of obligation and the example set
by her father can't be escaped Evelyn
isn't exactly Shackled to her family but
is the one who ensures their survival
she's forced to undertake some risky
Missions at least until the kids prove
they can protect themselves in that
light Reagan's Quest takes on a
different connotation killing the
monsters isn't the goal it's a means to
an end Reagan's real Mission revolves
around Freedom the freedom to live a
normal life and to escape the terror
that's plagued them since the alien
attack began a quiet place part 2 ends
on an image of Hope Reagan's plant
dangling from the radio station
microphone its disruptive signal being
broadcast to people all over America's
east coast and yet while this is clearly
supposed to be a sign of positive things
to come a quiet place part 2 proves time
and again that safety is an illusion and
that's without taking into account the
problems with Reagan's plan are people
really going to be listening to the
radio without headphones in a world or
sound attracts monsters if not how will
they ever realize that the random
screeching coming over the airwaves is
the key to their survival these are real
questions but to be fair in either Quiet
Place movie is perfect when it comes to
plot logic while a quiet place part 2
greatly expands our understanding of the
post-apocalyptic World there are a
number of questions that remain when the
credits begin narratively it's probably
for the best that these movies don't
delve into the larger socio-political
implications of the invasion but there
are still things we want to know about
our characters that the film simply
doesn't answer mainly what do Reagan and
Emmett do now do they return to the
steel plant and reunite with the rest of
the Abbott family or do they wait for
Evelyn Marcus and the baby to come to
them what is is the state of the Island
community now that it has been attacked
by a monster and many of its residents
are dead will life continue there like
it did before or is that Refuge gone as
mentioned before it's also not clear
exactly how Reagan's plan is going to
pan out either it feels like there are a
few more steps that need to be taken
before the monsters are in real trouble
finally after two movies are we ever
gonna learn that baby's name
if a quiet place part 2 performs well at
the box office a sequel seems almost
guaranteed what's less obvious is
whether or not the abbots will return on
top of the husband and wife team at the
head of the series may be being ready to
move on it kind of feels like the
Abbott's story is over it's not clear
how much room for growth they have left
the alien invasion was a global event
though and there are plenty of other
locations where people are probably
still struggling to survive what the
things look like in different climates
or other countries and what would this
world look like years down the line
abbots or no abbots The Quiet Place
movies thrive on being stories about
everyday people stick to that core and
the franchise could run for a very long
time
mid-samar is a movie about a
relationship Going Up in Flames
literally writer director Ari Astor has
described it as more of a breakup movie
than a horror film one that he hopes
will leave people quote feeling a little
bit confused about how to feel so what
happened
as Aster has explained in many
interviews mid-samar is about a
relationship coming to an end he told
USA Today the goal was ultimately to
make a big operatic breakup movie that
feels the way breakups actually feel
catastrophic like the world is ending
it's a an operatic breakup movie and um
and a dark contemporary fairy tale like
a lot of great horror movies you're not
really supposed to take everything that
happens in midsomar literally whether
all of this weird stuff is actually
happening isn't nearly as important as
how the characters react to it
particularly Danny Altered States and
hallucinations play a big role in
midsummar's story and subjectivity is
important to how the plot unfolds from
Danny's perspective the story plays out
as a series of increasingly shocking
revelations the movie looks a lot
different from the perspective of Pella
the member of the horga commune out of
all of Christian's friends who come to
the horga festival he's the only one who
knows what's going to happen that's why
you look so guilty right now because you
know the audience also gets competing
perspectives of Danny and Christian's
relationship the audience sees Danny
going through an incredibly traumatic
time needing the support of a loved one
more than ever but we also get a look at
Christian's perspective seeing a guy
who's falling out of love with his
girlfriend and tired of dealing with her
drama whether any of it is her fault or
not complicating matters are Christian's
friends most of whom clearly don't like
Danny and are encouraging Christian to
pull away you've been wanting out of
this stupid relationship for like a year
now Danny spends most of the movie as a
passive protagonist mostly only reacting
to events as they happen she doesn't
want to be a needy person and bends over
backwards to take the blame for her own
clinginess always going with the flow in
hopes of salvaging her relationship so
she ends up on a trip she didn't plan
under the influence of hallucinogens she
didn't intend to take she gives and she
gives hoping all the while that
Christian his friends or the world in
general will just give her a break
nothing in our life feels in our grasp
until the end of the movie when she's
finally crowned the May Queen and given
ultimate power over the commune after
spending the whole movie as a doormat
for Christian and his friends she ends
up symbolically at least in control of
their Fates
in mid-summar flowers represent family
with an early clue to the symbolism
being the floral wallpaper in the
bedroom of Danny's parents seen just
before they die the metaphor can be
extended to plants in general after the
death of Danny's Family the house plants
in her apartment are all dead in the
beginning of the movie Danny's world is
dark and frigid but things begin turning
around for her on the trip in a place
where the sun rarely stops shining and
flowers grow in abundance before Dany
even consciously realizes it she's being
introduced to a new family the first
person to wish Danny a happy birthday
the first birthday she's celebrating
without her family is Pella Danny truly
begins being pulled into the cult on the
final day when she joins in the
drug-fueled dance around the maypole for
the competition she's gifted a flowered
wreath after she wins and becomes the
May Queen she's soon seen literally up
to her neck in flowers all but smothered
by the horga's Adoration her brothers
and sisters if she'll have them it's a
mutually beneficial relationship the
commune often needs outside members in
order to avoid inbreeding and Danny
needs a new place to belong her old
family's lives were violently ended her
new family as a violent start
midsummar's violent yet somehow Serene
ending works on one level as classic
wicker man style folk horror but it's
also a strong metaphor for a dissolving
relationship early on in the movie Dany
a psychology student makes reference to
the psychological process of a breakup
seeing the signs of her dissolving
relationship in Christian's distancing
behavior in that sense the whole Bonkers
final sequence can be read as a
ritualistic look at how a relationship
comes to an end as the movie begins its
third act both Dany and Christian
alienate and agitate their friends with
their relationship woes they become
separated experiencing different parts
of the festival on their own Christian
goes into a trance-like state as he
cheats on Dany with Maya the commune
girl who's shown signs of being smitten
with him ever since his group arrived
since we've seen him be drugged and
hexed to the point where his mind seems
blank there is a strong sense that he is
not doing this voluntarily
urged on by sheer physical desire rather
than conscious thought it's the exact
story we see in a hanging tapestry
earlier in the movie meanwhile Danny
goes dancing on her own unconcerned
about Christian's whereabouts With a
Little Help from the horga the
long-suffering couple is finally coming
apart
Dany starts the movie surrounded by
people who don't appreciate her grief
worried that they'll abandon her the
only people who show her kindness seem
to be Pella and the horga after Danny
Bears witness to Christian and Maya
together in their ritualistic tryst she
begins to emotionally break down as she
does so she's surrounded by followers of
the May Queen all emphatically mimicking
her every noise and emotion despite the
obvious pain of the moment this sense of
true connection and empathy is what Dany
has spent the movie looking for she
screams and everyone around her screams
back unlike Christian or his friends
they share her pain ever since her
family died that's all she's really
wanted
one of the more amusing aspects about
midsomar's climax is the way the events
parallel fellow folklore film The Wicker
man as well as that movie's certifiably
insane Nicholas Cage starring remake
that movie inexplicably involved Cage's
character dressing up in a bear costume
to disguise himself before eventually
just running around punching people a
fact that's impossible not to think
about when Christian is rendered
paralyzed and sewn into a bare carcass
of his own it's the same bear briefly
shown caged up on the commune grounds
earlier in the movie not having a clear
purpose until the movie's bloody end
considering how much Aster has credited
the original wicker man with inspiring
midsomar it's not hard to read this
detail of the bear suit as an
intentional nod to the Remake adding a
bit of dark absurdist humor to the
movie's fiery climax
as Christian and the bodies of his
friends are being readied for ritual
sacrifice the proceedings are watched
over by a mysterious figure face
invisible behind a thick Veil The Script
for midsummar names this character as
veter the god of Vengeance but while
this figure obviously plays into some
kind of horga ritual he also serves as a
metaphor for dany's emotional state the
man refers to Christian wrapped up in
the bear carcass as a quote Mighty and
Dreadful Beast whose death will Purge
the horga Society of its quote most
Unholy affects even though she may not
have ordered it deliberately this
destructive ritual can be read as a very
personal reaction on the part of Dany on
Whose orders the commune is now
effectively acting whether she ordered
it or not this is an act of Vengeance on
her behalf after four years of dating
and a long slow withering of her romance
with Christian Danny is finally
asserting herself and guiding the
relationship to a permanent end after
spending the whole movie being passive
this sequence represents her consciously
Letting Go unleashing all of her pent-up
frustrations with Christian and his
friends to her relief and their Doom
seeing her smile could come as a total
shock it's cathartic it's weird and it
doesn't make a ton of literal sense but
it does make sense emotionally making
for a haunting final sequence that as
Astor said he intended melee viewers
perplexed about how they're supposed to
feel
a quiet place is triumphantly tiptoed
into theaters enjoying critical Acclaim
as well as success at the box office
director John Krasinski delivers a
thriller with a unique concept and a
cleverly limited set of cinematic tools
unlike most modern mainstream movies
it's a film that relies Less on spoken
dialogue than on ambient sounds of
visuals and mystery a quiet place
introduces the Abbott family who tried
to survive on their secluded Farm after
a worldwide invasion of creatures that
hunt by sound getting by with a variety
of creative sound dampening Solutions
and communicating with sign language
they face the challenges of adolescents
guilds and even a pregnancy their story
builds to a climax that wraps up the
action while leaving a few questions
still unanswered if you want to know
more about just what went down in the
final minutes keep quiet and check out
our spoiler-filled rundown this is the
ending of a quiet place explained
Rocket's red glare in a quiet place's
opening scene a youngest child Beau
proposes that a rocket ship could help
the family Escape his fascination with
space travel proves to be his downfall
as a toy shuttle in his hands makes
enough electric noise to attract one of
the creatures his family watches
helplessly as a boy is snatched away
just before the main title Bo's death
informs the character Rags for the rest
of the story as the film jumps ahead a
year and finds everyone struggling with
grief and guilt while attempting to
maintain some sense of normalcy under
the oppressive silence his memory plays
a key role in the finale as the monsters
move in on Evelyn Abbott when she goes
into labor her husband Lee and their son
Marcus draw them away by putting into
action a one-word plan Rockets while the
farm glows red with the warning lights
that signal and attack a body of
fireworks distracts the Beast and allows
Lee to take back the house and rejoin
his wife and newborn son sacrificial
Scream one of acquired places Central
plot threads focuses on Lee and Evelyn's
daughter Reagan and her strained
relationship with her father as the one
who gave Beau the toy that led to his
death Reagan thinks that Lee blames her
leads over protective Tendencies towards
his deaf daughter don't exactly help her
feel that he believes in her either in
one of the film's key scenes Marcus
reminds his father that he needs to tell
Reagan how much he loves her it is a
huge emotional payoff then when Lee
rescues Marcus and Reagan from a
creature and tells him that he has
always loved them while the kids take
shelter inside a pickup truck with the
Beast clawing to get inside Lee lets out
one final anguish scream giving his life
to save them as they throw the truck
into neutral and it rolls back to the
house it's a cathartic moment not only
for the three characters but for the
audience as well to break the Silence
with a tragic but triumphant emotional
release
all ears the greatest mystery of a quiet
place Remains the creatures themselves
aside from some vague news headlines
there is barely any Exposition given
about where they come from or just how
The Invasion went down for most of the
film's run time the monsters are
glimpsed only briefly appearing as
fleeting blurs or vague shapes the
climax however finally reveals them in
all their gruesome Glory as one of them
stalks Evelyn and her newborn baby into
the basement of The Farmhouse they have
eyeless heads that splits open in all
directions to expose sensitive hearing
membranes in addition to delivering a
horrific visual this design explains a
physiology that allows the bees to so
accurately strike at even the subtlest
sounds
ferocious feedback a unique aspect of a
quiet place is its use of American Sign
Language to convey the vast majority of
the dialogue Krasinski chose to hire a
Death actress to portray the hearing
impaired Reagan for the sake of
authenticity and he worked with her to
develop signing habits and styles that
informed each family member's attitude
and character Arc the monster's weakness
was at last revealed to be feedback as
the noise emitted from Reagan's cochlear
implant when they are near confuses
their heightened sense and racks them
with pain during the final confrontation
Reagan discovers a pile of discarded
custom boosted implants that Lee had
been working on showing how much he
cared for her while also providing her
with the ability to fight back for the
first time
locked and loaded Reagan uses Lee's
radio transmitter to amplify the
feedback causing the Intruder to recoil
disoriented and exposes inner membranes
ever then takes the opportunity of
having a clear shot at this weak spot
for the first time and blows the thing
away with a shotgun naturally this is
the kind of loud sound the abbots have
been avoiding as Lee's security monitors
show the other two creatures known to
inhabit the area racing toward the
Farmhouse but Evelyn's ready this time
and gives her daughter a reassuring
Smile as she [ __ ] a shotgun in the
movie cuts to credits sending the
audience out of the theater without
releasing their adrenaline High the Next
Generation
Evelyn's pregnancy and labor are a
driving source of tension for most of a
quiet place and it's not just to harvest
the audience's anxieties a major theme
of the film is to struggle to survive
and adapt to some kind of normalcy in
the midst of horrific societal changes
that's why the invasion occurs before
the Story begins and the Rebellion
against the monsters is saved for after
its ending Evelynn leaves newborn baby
serves as a symbol for the belief that
life can go on children will be born who
never knew life before the quiet who are
we we can't protect them Reagan Marcus
and the baby at their mother's side in
the film's final moments represent what
this story is all about the future
this wildly profitable socially themed
horror comedy was one of the biggest
success stories of 2017. still it's easy
to get a little lost in all the action
and hard-hitting subtext on the screen
during the Final Act to help you make
sense of it all here's get out's ending
explained
hi
I'm Roman amitesh
the ultimate reveal at the end of get
out is so organically earned that the
weight of it can be hard to understand
on first viewing when Chris goes to meet
his white girlfriend Rose's parents for
the first time he's apprehensive he said
I was the first black guy you ever did
yeah so what yeah so is his Uncharted
Territory you know I don't want to get
chased off the lawn with a shotgun
at first his fears seemed ridiculous
since Missy and Dean seem perfectly nice
if awkward however Dean drops some early
foreshadowing when he reminisces about
when his father lost the race to Jesse
Owens
tough break for your dad though yeah
he almost got over it
as the audience and Chris soon learned
the armitageas and their friends are
planning to steal Chris's body as part
of a plan to live forever in the bodies
of kidnapped black people Dean's musing
about his father's loss to a black man
hints early on that the armitageas
aren't exactly as jovial as they seem
later in the film Chris is hypnotized
against his will by Missy and introduced
to the sunken place now you're in the
sunken place
what exactly is the sunken place it's a
visual display of what happens when
Chris is paralyzed through hypnosis but
according to director Jordan peel it
also represents the reality of living as
a marginalized person peel tweeted we
are all in the sunken place we're
marginalized no matter how hard we
scream the system silences us
unfortunately Chris soon learns that
racism is a family business and that his
girlfriend Rose is a willing participant
in her family's crimes for years she's
been luring black people back to her
family's home to be hypnotized for dark
purposes as Chris wakes up paralyzed in
a chair he finds out just how terrifying
the Armitage family really is a video
reveals that the family is part of a
cult called the order of coagula
originally led by Rose's grandfather the
video goes on to say that the order of
coagula developed a method of Life
Extension through brain transplants
young black people were sought out for
these operations for the perceived
Superior physical traits the black
people are lobotomized preserving only a
shadow of the host's Consciousness
forever doomed to reside as a paralyzed
passenger in its own body their brains
are replaced with the consciousness of
Rich old white people interested in
immortality
it's already been established that
Chris's response to hypnosis is to panic
scratch at a chair's upholstery this
winds up being his Saving Grace Chris is
able to pull some cotton from the chair
he's been confined to and stuff it in
his ears so that he isn't affected by
the hypnotic sound after gaining the
upper hand on the armitage's in a
satisfyingly violent sequence Chris gets
in a car and tries to escape in the
process he comes to a final
confrontation with his former girlfriend
Rose by the end of it Rose lies wounded
on the ground telling Chris that she
still loves him
thank you
[Music]
I love you I love you Chris sees through
the lie and Begins the Strangler but
after their time together he just can't
bring himself to go through with it as
he lets up on Rose we see a police car's
red and blue lights flashing earlier in
the film Rose and Chris are pulled over
despite the fact that Rose is driving
the police officer asked to see Chris's
ID and he hands it over sadly accustomed
to being profiled by the law so when the
police lights flash in the movie's final
moments we fear that Chris will be shot
or railroaded into prison by a racist
police officer luckily it isn't a police
car but rather a TSA vehicle driven by
Chris's pal Rod Chris walks away from
Rose leaving her to possibly die from
her wounds and gets in Rod's car finally
free from the armitage's Twisted scheme
it's a mostly happy ending but peel
nearly ripped out audiences hearts with
an alternate deleted ending in the
alternate ending it's not Rod who turns
up to save the day but the actual police
Chris is blamed for the deaths at the
Armitage house and arrested and the
scene cuts the rod visiting Chris in
prison the movie ends with Chris
accepting his fate in prison secure in
the knowledge that at least he stopped
what was happening
stop doing
but as Chris hangs up the phone we can
see the dozens of black men that are in
prison with him and we know that Chris
didn't really stop anything he just
stopped one particularly Fantastical
symptom of racism ultimately peel went
with the theatrical ending because he
felt like the deleted one was just too
heavy for an audience that needed a
break he told variety that it was very
clear that the ending needed to
transform into something that gives us a
hero that gives us an escape gives us a
positive feeling when we leave this
movie
and get out to the order of coagula are
not the kind of societal Outcast races
that are usually depicted in movies
these are socially accepted otherwise
upstanding citizen racists who keep
their true evil hidden by falsehoods and
platitudes
but don't please don't let me into that
you know I can give you what what color
you are now by revealing their professed
admiration for the black race as
fetishistic and opportunistic peel
revealed an unspoken larger truth that
resonated with audiences worldwide using
the micro regressions that people of
color deal with in their everyday lives
as the signals for more Sinister motives
peel created a story that succeeds both
as an engrossing Thriller and is
appointed social commentary
the terrifying Hellraiser Saga
surrounding Pinhead and his nefarious
band of cinebites continues in
Hellraiser judgment with more puzzle
boxes hapless victims and of course a
few trips to 55 lodovico place this time
there's a Serial Slayer on the loose in
the Earthly realm Doling out Justice for
various violations of the Ten
Commandments as some sort of sick scheme
to win God's favor meanwhile Pinhead and
his Pals have been exacting their own
brand of justice and hell and when the
Two Worlds Collide well there's you know
what to pay
let's take a look at how the story draws
everything together and sets up the next
round of hellraising
harsh judgment pinhead's new right-hand
man or thing is the most interesting
addition to the film called the auditor
this slash face Baddie begins the
process of Eternal judgment on pinhead's
behalf
I have a mindful home pain he's nothing
more than a common currency naturally
this is all very gross for everyone
involved after the auditor types up a
human's confession another sidekick
called the assessor Chows down on the
pages and regurgitates them up for a
trio of jurors who rifle through the
contents and then render their verdict
punishment then begins with a disgusting
saliva bath before the subject is sent
to the Butcher and the surgeon for some
key rearrangements so yeah it's foul in
every imaginable way and whoever ends up
at the Cotton house is in for quite an
unpleasant surprise unless
detective with a dark side at first
we're led to believe that detective Sean
Carter is just a man who's far too into
his job of hunting down serial killers
he comes home late to his angry wife
can't seem to stay away from work and is
even being investigated by the case's
newest pair of eyes detective Christine
Edgerton is here to help but she also
believes he might be suffering from PTSD
from his War service and May maybe
dabbling in drugs or alcohol his brother
David who is somehow his partner in
crime fighting thinks he's a rational
and good person and gladly follows him
down whatever Rabbit Hole as
investigations take him through by the
end of the film however we find out that
looks have been very deceiving when it
comes to Sean
which is a terrible ponderous chain you
are making he's actually the one who's
taken on the mantle of righteous death
dealer slaughtering people who run afoul
of the Ten Commandments in pretty much
any way shape or form between him
underlining the same Charles Dickens
quotes from the crime scenes to his
obsession with Ecclesiastes which
roughly translates to the very name of
the man they're after he implicates
himself pretty well along the way
what was it he said only God can judge
me God will judge the righteous
and his crimes are unspeakable he saws
off the hands eyeballs and Teeth of some
teens while they're still alive simply
because they committed petty theft he
surgically implants a woman's womb with
her still living dog because she says in
a phone video that she worships the
animal it's so bad that even the
assessor can't stomach the taste of his
confessions and yet he manages to escape
judgment twice because of a demand from
on high
the powers that be it seems like Pinhead
holds the ultimate authority over how
guilty people are treated in his domain
but when the Archangel Joe field shows
up and insists that David be sent back
to Earth to finish his work which at
first we think is just solid policing
pinhead's team has no choice but to
concede
[Music]
just let him go
Pinhead still sends his Stitch twins
along to Honda's nightmares but he
mostly steers clear of Sean after Sean
brings himself back to pinhead's realm
again though in the hopes of trading his
brother and wife for his own soul being
cleared Pinhead and his auditor refused
to bargain with him or Joe field they're
ready to move on to the punishment phase
and chaining Sean's brother and wife up
to a state of Eternal suffering won't
satisfy their bloodlust jophiel wants
him to be sent back to Earth to carry on
with his commandment Slaughters so more
people will turn to the almighty for
protection this makes Sean believe his
plan is falling into place but jophiel
informs him that he's not getting any
Absolution out of this Arrangement he'll
still be pen head's property after it's
all said and done but she just wants to
buy him more time for his bad deeding
the trouble is panhead's grown wary of
blindly obeying Joe feels demands the
final Judgment at first Pinhead obliges
jophiel's request to return Sean to the
living so he can score the good side
some Souls but when Sean regains
Consciousness he's immediately waxed by
detective Edgerton who's now figured out
he's the big bad they've been looking
for Sean's instant demise puts him back
in pinhead's clutches for good this time
and that angers Joe field who threatens
to bring down the wrath of her boss for
his insolence pen head decides he's got
nothing to lose though he's already in
hell and was basically built to endure
such suffering so how much worse could
it get for him not only does he ignore
her warnings Pinhead also proceeds to
throw the angel into his chains and lets
them rip her to shreds even the auditor
knows his boss is made a massive mistake
as he points out Joe feel was the angel
who banished Adam and Eve from the
Garden of Eden and if she could do it to
them she could do something similar to
Pinhead just as all those he's judged
have awoken to the harsh consequences of
their mistakes the last scene finds a
humanized version of Pinhead banished
from his realm of sweet suffering and
sent to the Mortal realm meanwhile the
post-credits scene opens the door for
the auditor to take over altogether as
he's shown in Hanover Germany welcoming
two unsuspecting missionaries into his
lethal lair
[Music]
what does our final shots of Stanley Q
breaks The Shining really mean and what
happens to the traumatized characters
Left Alive it's time to talk about those
questions and dig up some answers
in order to survive the events of The
Shining Danny Torrence was forced to
escape his own father in a freezing
hedge Maze and flee a haunted hotel
where he'd seen enough freaky surf to
seriously mess up even your average
adult
[Music]
come and play with us standing
so while he lived to tell the tale it's
tough to imagine Dany has a normal life
waiting for him in the aftermath if you
want to go with Stephen King's version
of events Danny's future is at least
partially written in the 2013 novel Dr
sleep King's official sequel to The
Shining a grown Danny Torrance suffers
from alcoholism like his father Dany
gets the job at a nursing home where
he's able to help guide the dying into
the next realm he eventually encounters
a girl with abilities like his own and
fights to save her from a group of
psychic vampires sounds strange dogged
asleep is headed for the big screen in
late 2019 so you can see it for yourself
the most debated element of the
shining's ending is a final shot showing
Jack in the photo of the overlooks 1921
4th of July party which could mean a few
things it could be that in death Jack
has been absorbed into the overlook's
history and now walks the Haunted World
where all eras seem to be happening at
once it could also be that the photo is
the hotel's way of showing that Jack's
descent into madness was a fulfillment
of some kind of Twisted Destiny one
particular interpretation has been
adopted by many of the film's hardcore
fans the overlooked long series of
caretaker murders and the fact that it
was built on an Indian burial ground
suggests that the hotel is a place where
history repeats itself many believe Jack
was a reincarnated Soul who was always
meant to be part of that cycle he was
destined to return to the hotel and
recreate its bloody past according to
the theory this is what the spectral
Grady means during the conversation in
the red bathroom when he tells Jack
oh the caretaker
you've always been the caretaker
if you watch The Shining all the way
through get to that final shot of Jack
in the photo and then we watch it you
will notice something that stands out
about the Overlook there are framed
black and white photos chronicling the
hotel's history everywhere dozens of
them all in identical frames all
covering the hotel's illustrious history
if Jack was a Reincarnation of a past
guest or caretaker and he was always on
the photo how long will it be before
someone notices him there and if he's
there it stands to reason that Grady
would be there too proving he was also a
victim of the cycle of reincarnation and
violence if the Fallout from the latest
overlooked tragedy goes on long enough
those photos will likely mean something
to someone and that will set off an
entirely different kind of Investigation
early in The Shining when Dick Halloran
sits down with Dany to explain to him
what The Shining is he tells the boy
that he's not alone
but there are other folks though mostly
they don't know I don't believe it
considering both Halloran and Dany two
of the rare Souls of their psychic gift
find themselves in the Overlook does
this mean that in the world of The
Shining people of the gift are drawn to
places with powerful Supernatural
presences or are they able to sense the
spirits present wherever they are the
film only scratches the surface but as
dick draws closer to his violent end
dany's journey is just beginning
boy you read my thoughts You've Got The
Shining you mean shining you want to get
sued
The Shining is a film about cyclical
violence and about how he can't escape
the dark Specter of History The Overlook
is built on the sacred lands of Native
Americans who are slaughtered in the
name of expansion and blood continues to
spill there Jack torrance's own history
with violence doesn't begin in the
Overlook but years before when he heard
his son drawing a drunken binge that's
why when Wendy sees Danny injured she
immediately assumes it was Jack who hurt
him just as he overlooked user's jug to
continue its own bloody tradition it
traps him back in his own past when
drinking allows him to cross the line
into violence but this time the stakes
are much higher than a broken bone or
two I'm not gonna hurt you I'm just
gonna bash your brains like Jack The
Overlook has its own grisly cycle first
the Native Americans killed for its
creation Grady murdering his family and
now Jack attempting to slaughter his
wife and son it's quite possible there
were others we never heard about
fortunately Wendy and Dany escape the
hotel relatively unscathed at least
physically does this mean that through
their survival they've somehow broken
the cycle does this mean that overlooks
Eva will sway is at least somewhat
lessened the film doesn't make the
answer clear but there is hope
when the Netflix original film the
platform dropped in February 2020 the
Spanish horror Thriller quickly
generated a ton of Buzz for its unique
dystopian setting under pressure and
symbolism at the core of the narrative
at first glance the film appears to be a
story of individual greed and the
struggle to survive but as the movie
reaches its haunting conclusion it
becomes clear that there's something
deeper going on at the outset of the
platform we're introduced to Goring a
new inmate in a vertical prison at the
top a team of chefs prepare a lavish
Feast big enough to feed everyone in the
hundreds of cells below and each day the
titular platform containing the food is
lowered the platform stops at each cell
for two minutes and the two prisoners in
that cell can eat as much or as little
as they want of course those at the top
get their fill while those at the bottom
are left with nothing and end up
starving the catches that the prisoners
are assigned a new cell each month
rearranging the pecking order in
relation to the platform the ambiguous
sending of the platform and the film's
metaphorical nature throughout have left
many viewers trying to to figure out
what it all means let's run through the
symbolism of the movie and what message
the filmmakers wanted us to take away
from the final moments we get bits of
details about what the purpose of the
prison is throughout but it's not until
Goring meets Emma Geary who works for
the prison herself before becoming an
inmate that we get a more concrete idea
emo Geary tells Goring that the
administration prefers to refer to the
pit-like prison as a vertical
self-management Center or VSC she
explains that in order for the food to
reach all the way down to the lowest
levels there needs to be a spontaneous
sense of solidarity meaning everyone
without communicating to one another
only takes as much as they need she
seems to imply that the whole purpose of
the prison is to create a system in
which people can learn to Foster the
spontaneous sense of solidarity however
Goring proposes a more Sinister
interpretation
if that solidarity emerged they would
know how to avoid it from happening
outside wouldn't they according to
goring's interpretation of the prison
it's a small-scale model of a harsh
capitalist system and the rolling
classes using to test the responses of
the proletariat it's a toll for the
rulers not society as a whole most of
the main characters we meet in the
platform represent archetypes or ideas
larger than themselves for instance
Goring who volunteers to enter the pit
in order to obtain a college diploma
represents an idealistic intellectual at
the beginning of the film he shames
agreed of those who take more than their
share when they have the opportunity but
doesn't understand why they do it as he
has yet to spend a month at the bottom
of the pit similarly emagiri represents
a willfully ignorant bureaucrats upon
which a system like the VSC will lie in
order to function when omagiri enters
the pit it's revealed that she's mostly
in the dark as to what exactly happens
in there like gorang as he attempts to
convince the prisoners below her to
ration their food but they don't listen
to her please perhaps the most enigmatic
character in the platform is maharu a
beautiful woman who writes the platform
each month in search of her young child
Mahari was disdained by the fellow
prisoners and is often attacked even
amagiri derides her struggle claiming
that her search for her child is a lie
because nobody under 16 is allowed in
the pit maharu represents those who
suffer from the periphery of society
whose stories we don't want to believe
because they sound so cruel that we
can't imagine that we live in the same
system for instance people experiencing
homelessness or other forms of extreme
poverty at the end of the film we
learned that maharu's child is real and
has been living at the very bottom of
the pit Goring arrives there after
riding the platform down with a weapon
enforcing the rationing of the food by
beating and killing anyone who tries to
take more than their share his plan is
to return back to the top level with an
uneaten dessert a symbol that the
prisoners have learned how to work
together to survive in such a way
however after finding the child Goring
realizes that that isn't the message he
needs to send the discovery of maharu's
child is confirmation of the most
important component of the VSC
experiment those in power set the rules
but they clearly don't follow them
themselves although they've assured
everyone they would never do something
as cruel as allow a child into such a
horrendous existence that was a lie the
conclusion of the platform sees gorings
sending the child back up on the
platform as a message to the chefs at
the top who are presumably in a similar
state of ignorance as Emma Gary instead
of proving to them that the prisoners
can adapt to the system he wants to show
them that the system itself is
unspeakably and unfathomably cruel and
those operating it cannot be trusted
part of the Blair Witch Mania that took
hold in the Years following the film's
release was due to its ambiguous ending
what did it mean was the tragic fate
that befelled the three aspiring
filmmakers of Supernatural one or was it
something more human let's investigate
the most popular theories surrounding
the abrupt ending of The Blair Witch
Project
the backstory to The Blair Witch Project
included the relationships between its
fictional filmmakers Heather Donahue
Joshua Leonard and Michael Williams
Josh's backstory included a previous
relationship with Heather and they'd
worked together on a few documentaries
prior to Blair Witch this makes it all
the more upsetting for Heather when Josh
vanishes from their tent after a
particularly depressing day when the
group hiked for hours only to end up in
the same place Mike and Heather's first
night alone turns even darker when they
hear Josh screaming in agony but can't
locate him
Josh
is over here no it's over here
production designer Ben Rock explained
that Josh had been taken to record the
screams in a studio and they were then
played for Heather and Michael in the
woods Heather wakes up to find a strange
bundle of sticks outside of her tent
inside the bundle was a Swatch of Josh's
actual flannel shirt a lock of his hair
and what was meant to be Josh's teeth
which rock confirmed were actual human
teeth at producer Greg Hale got from a
dentist the bundle also ties the torture
of Josh to other Blair Witch mythology
which claims that in 1825 a ten-year-old
child was seen being pulled into tappy
East Creek near burkettsville Maryland
the film's website explains that her
body was never recovered and 13 days
after the drowning the creek is clogged
with oily bundles of sticks
on the second night following Josh's
disappearance Heather and Mike come to a
strange house in the woods the film's
directors and writers Daniel Myrick and
Eduardo Sanchez explained that according
to Blair Witch lore something really
dramatic happens in those woods every 40
to 50 years the timeline of the lore
begins in 1785 when Ellie kedward is
accused of Witchcraft by a group of
children kedward is found guilty and
banished to the woods to die during a
harsh winter following this event
strange events take place in the woods
including the modern case of the
burkettsville seven in 1940 seven
children were reported missing from the
town of burkettsville formerly known as
Blair and are found buried in the cellar
of town resident Ruston Parr par is
later executed for his crimes based on
the testimony of Kyle Brody a child who
managed to escape these deaths are
mentioned early in the Blair Witch
Project when Heather interviews locals
about the legend in describing that part
of the shoot Sanchez confirmed that the
house was meant to be parr's house in
both the player which documentaries
within the movie Parr confesses to the
killings
all accounts The Blair Witch
Mike charges into the PowerHouse while
recording yelling to Josh and
encouraging Heather to follow him we see
Mike and Heather's points of view sweep
over the house which only becomes more
unsettling as they encounter strange
symbols written on the walls the symbols
are from an alphabet known as transitus
fluvii which is from a book of Occult
Philosophy that's supposedly practiced
by you guessed it witches benrock
confirmed that the creative team on The
Blair Witch Project used this to
decorate the par house the letters also
pop up in the Sci-Fi fictional special
the curse of the Blair Witch which was
heir to promote the release of The Blair
Witch Project during the tale of coffin
Rock the mythology explains that coffin
rock is the site where a search party
sent out after a missing girl in 1886
were brutally killed according to the
film archivist Chris Carrasco in the
curse of the Blair Witch the strange
symbols aren't the only creepy image
decorating par's house Heather and
Mike's cameras revealed dozens of
child-sized handprints all over the
crumbling walls these were obviously
left behind by pars victim all of which
were children Rock said Dan had the idea
for the kids hand prints from one time
he'd gone to someone's filthy house and
their dogs had made a giant black smear
at dog height throughout the house for
the actual movie The handprints were
made using black paint applied to the
hands of art director Ricardo Moreno's
young nephews
it's one of the most memorable moments
from The Blair Witch Project along with
Heather's up the nose camera confession
after running downstairs Heather's
camera swings around to reveal Mike
standing in the corner of the basement
with his back to her despite her blood
curdling screams he doesn't move this
final frame of the film left audiences
scratching their heads leaving Artisan
entertainment the company that purchased
the Blair Witch Project at the Sundance
Film Festival only hours after its debut
for 1.1 million dollars afraid that the
ending was too confusing Myrick later
told Entertainment Weekly when we
screened it people were overwhelmingly
confused however when asked if they were
scared 19 out of 20 hands went up
originally there was no explanation for
why Mike remained Frozen in the corner
under pressure from Artisan the team did
some reshoots in Maryland and added
interviews in which townspeople talk
about Rustin Parr and The Disappearance
of the original burkettsville 7. the
interviews alluded to the idea that Parr
made the children face the wall so as to
not witness the horrors inflicted on
their fellow victims
so what really happened in the end
there's no definitive answer and the
filmmakers intended it that way director
Eduardo Sanchez said there's no Rhyme or
Reason to what's happening in those
woods you were never meant to know one
Theory suggests the filmmakers are
actually victims of the burkettsville
townspeople after two nights in the
woods Heather and Josh discussed the
Unexplained sounds they've been hearing
at night saying
but nobody knows we're out here yeah but
you ever seen Deliverance
referring to the 1972 film Deliverance
in which a group of men are stocked in
the Woods by deranged locals in a
deleted scene included on the Blair
Witch DVD release Josh proposes that
locals they encountered in town during
filming are making a game of stalking
the team and that this is the cause of
the strange incidents fans of this
theory suggest Mike is standing in the
corner at the end because he's being
held at gunpoint by an unseen person
while Heather is then knocked out others
say that Mary Brown the strange woman
interviewed at the start of the film is
one of these people as the wooden gate
to her mobile home looks similar to both
the stick figures and the bundle of
Josh's teeth
another popular fan theory is that Josh
either lost his mind and killed Mike and
Heather or that Mike and Josh both
conspired to kill Heather together the
number of people crewing the documentary
shoot also seems suspiciously small most
camera operators use assistance as
refilling a 16 millimeter camera is an
involved process and would be
challenging for amateurs shooting in the
woods at night not to mention how heavy
all that equipment would be to carry did
Josh and Mike purposely go into the
woods with Heather alone because they
had more Sinister motives Heather's
diary recovered under a hundred-year-old
cabin by an archeology class a year
after the filmmakers went missing has
some interesting notes on the behavior
of her crew the journal details
suspicions that Mike and Josh aren't
sleeping the creative team when
describing how they communicated with
the actors to avoid direct contact
explained that one of their notes read
Josh is slowly losing his mind Mike also
admits to throwing away the team's map
in what can only be a possible Act of
sabotage a deleted scene reveals that
Josh actually crumpled up the map and
threw it on the ground before Mike
destroyed it meaning both men were lying
to Heather about not knowing its
whereabouts
in the curse of the Blair Witch it's
explained that Rustin parr's house was
burned by townspeople following his
arrest so how were Mike and Heather able
to run around a house that had been
burned to the ground in the 1940s how is
it that the filmmakers walked south from
a river for hours only to end up in the
same place Heather's Journal reads I had
the compass out all day all three of us
checked it every five minutes we were
going south all day
there's also the strange fact that the
equipment and footage was found in the
colonial era foundations of a burned
down house David Mercer the archeology
Professor who led his class to the site
explains that even a forensic expert
could not have placed those items
without leaving signs of disturbance the
time warp theory contends that Heather
Mike and Josh hiked into an area of the
woods where time is altered leading them
to hike in circles and to a time when
parr's house is still standing and that
it was par who killed Heather there
while ordering Mike to stand in the
corner this theory is connected to
2016's Blair Witch film which wasn't
made by the original filmmakers but has
a concept supported in the Blair Witch
canon in the original pitch video for
the 1999 movie shown on the show split
screen narration explains that sections
of the Black Hills area are lost in time
once entered there is no way out
of all the endings suggested by fans
over the years the interpretation with
the most evidence is that the Blair
Witch or a spirit associated with her
possessed the filmmakers this led them
astray and turned them against each
other or used unseen figures to dispose
of them producer Greg Hale explains
kedward actually wasn't a witch but she
did a couple of things that kind of made
people suspect her he told Screen Rant
that kedward was blamed for witchcraft
and after being banished to the woods
quote she kind of became the conduit for
this thing as did Rustin Parr in the 40s
Sanchez often refers to this power as
the entity which possibly predates human
history and notes but the responsibility
for triggering the evil falls on human
shoulders eventually and the film itself
depicts some possible Supernatural
events Mike is screaming loudly as he
runs through par's house in the final
minutes of the film when suddenly his
voice cuts off that leaves us with the
knowledge that whatever lured Mike and
Heather into the house was capable of
controlling Mike silently Hale implied
that the entity does doesn't only use
kedward to carry out its evil Deeds
saying it just looks for a way to affect
people and do things
in one interview with the townspeople a
resident says what Rustin Parr did with
his victims stating
he took the kids down in the basement by
twos he made one face into the corner
really
and then he would kill the other one
just when you think you've got the Blair
Witch Project figured out it manages to
throw you another curveball for all the
talk of an entity possessing Ellie
kedward Rustin Parr or any of the other
figures who might be responsible for
torturing the missing filmmakers the
initial burkettsville 7 goes unmentioned
Rock gave the inside scoop to dread
Central a few years ago much debate had
gone into the ending of the film
throughout the process and the final
compromise concept was that the children
Rustin Parr had killed would have done
this so after Heather's camera went down
those of us outside the house were to
run in and gingerly run around as if we
were children who'd been freed and when
we did Heather made that final scream
you hear in the movie that guttural
manifestation and we all ran into the
middle of the house and ran around on
the wood floor like idiots give us the
possession theories all day long we draw
the line at creepy Spirit children for
our own well-being
don't like that conclusion several years
ago Sanchez and Myrick confirmed that
when Artisan pressured them to change
the film's ending to make it more
definitive they ended up shooting four
alternate versions that were never used
these very unsubtle alternate endings
range from seeing Mike surrounded by
Stickman figures to him being hanged or
crucified they're pretty universally
reviled so it's a good thing Artisan
decided to trust the instincts of their
filmmakers Myrick said what makes us
fearful is something that's out of the
ordinary unexplained the first ending
kept the audience off balance it
challenged our real world conventions
and that's what really made it scary
2008 The Strangers was a simple story of
a random home invasion that resonated
with audiences worldwide while its box
office performance warranted a sequel no
one thought it would take nearly 10
years to happen but now the strangers
have returned and though they might be
in a new setting with a new cast the
threat the Invaders present Remains the
Same The Strangers prey at night follows
a family of four parents Cindy and Mike
their son Luke and their daughter Kinsey
when they set off to visit relatives in
a Countryside trailer park their
vacation turns to Tara when a trio of
masked Invaders descends on the family
with murder on their minds now that
we're all safe at home let's break down
the ending of The Strangers prey at
night spoilers ahead
the pool is closed the climax of the
movie kicks into high gear once the
parents are out of the picture as Kinsey
and Luke set off to flee the trailer
park but after a nasty encounter with
dollface Luke tells Kinsey to lay in
hiding while he Sprints for help alone
he doesn't get very far when he makes it
to the trailer parks pool he comes face
to face with the ax-wielding man in The
Mask Luke puts up a struggle taking the
fight into the water but his overpowered
cut up and left to drown it seems like
things are over until two hands burst
into the water and pull him up it's
kinzei back on her feet there to save
her brother in the nick of time with his
wounds much more severe than hers the
siblings switched places as Luke hides
away while Kinsey makes a break for it
stumbling into the street to a passing
police officer who shows up so out of
nowhere that Kinsey can barely believe
her eyes as Kinsey falls into the arms
of the officer neither of them notices a
killer doll face approaching from behind
by the time that Kinsey sees her it's
too late to do anything but watch the
officer get murdered one shot one kill
in one of the movie's most harrowing
moments Kinsey tries to commandeer the
police car while doll face overpowers
her pushing her into the passenger seat
as she stabs at her over and over and
just when you think it's all over Kinsey
gets tactical where is she a police car
and this one has a shotgun the movie's
most hopeless scene pivots to his most
triumphant moment as Kinsey grubs a
shotgun and executes a doll fate with
one brutal blast of the head
I Think We're Alone Now after surviving
another scrape McKinsey tries to start
up the police car while a truck pulls up
alongside Kinsey it's the man in the
mask of course both strangers movies are
notable for showcasing the playful
sadism of The Killers often they get a
chance to execute their victims and just
don't preferring to terrify and taunt
their prey there's no reason why that's
what's so horrible about it they found
people that are awake and they thought
that that would be a fun thing to do is
to torment them in the sequel It's a
tactic that works against them allowing
their victims just enough chances to get
lucky get away or get revenge this time
the man in the mask's taunt of choice
involves cranking the volume on
Tiffany's I Think We're Alone Now it's
an on the nose Choice the music is great
because I mean you're screaming you're
crying and then you have beautiful music
that like my mom grew up in that used to
be happy and pool parties and like
summer vacations playing over it Twisted
Metal
The Man in The Mask backs up and smashes
into Kinsey's car until both vehicles
explode into flames here the ultimate
stranger begins to appear to be
unkillable surviving the explosion to
chase down Kinsey and his flaming truck
while she flees on foot by then the fire
has burned off the Man's mask but it's
also burned away the Flesh of his face
with the killer remaining Anonymous
right down to the bone this moment as
well as an earlier instance where Kinsey
declines an opportunity to remove doll
Face's mask it's sort of the whole point
of both films they're monster movies
that don't have any monsters in them The
Killers aren't Freddy Krueger they're
just people and they could be anybody in
the original The Killers removed their
masks off camera making the point that
their true identities don't matter
that's what makes them all so scary if
you survived an encounter like this how
could you ever trust a stranger again
the thing that I love is that I don't
know who the strangers are and I think
they have absolutely no reason to do it
that's what's scary
The Hitchhiker Kinsey sticks to the
roads as she runs pursued on foot by The
Man in The Mask as a pickup truck
approaches just as you think the
encounter is only going to up the
Killer's body count luck turns Kinsey's
way again she leaps into the back of the
truck screaming as a burnt of axemen
grabs and swings at her the truck builds
up speed the killer loses his grip and
Kinsey escapes the ending is highly
reminiscent of the conclusion of the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre and just as
open-ended
[Music]
both Texas Chainsaw cuts to credits at
that point The Strangers prey at night
continues and that's when things get
ambiguous
the Bittersweet and
the movie ends on the reveal that
Kinsey's Escape led to Luke's rescue
with the newly orphaned siblings
reunited and alive in a dark hospital
room safe for the machines the room is
silent until there's a knock at the door
Kinsey doesn't panic but she's paralyzed
someone's outside the door a stranger
but is it really a killer
you lock him out
the truth doesn't really matter the
ending is a metaphor for trauma and the
last thing affects her the horrifying
experience can have on a person's psyche
what did her family do to deserve this
torment nothing and nothing they could
have done would have prevented it
to us
it gives you a home
the fate of her family was tied to the
whims of three strangers and at least
one of them could still be out there the
knock at the door is probably a nurse a
doctor a family friend but after this
experience no matter what Kinsey can
never put her trust in the kindness of
strangers again
oh you went and saw Suspiria maybe you
even sat through the whole thing this
two and a half hour journey is
definitely not the sort of movie-going
experience that goes down well for
everybody we're sure you have a few
questions
around suspiria's midpoint Madame Blanc
the Marcos Dance Company's top
instructor begins to develop a new dance
concept centering around the theme of
rebirth by then we're well aware that
the company is secretly a friend for an
ancient coven of witches who seem to be
violently sacrificing young dancers for
nefarious reasons while the details of
blanc's plans aren't made totally
explicit her proposal heavily implies
that the dance will be used to resurrect
the coven's ailing leader the witch
called mother Marcos it also looks like
the Feats will require a human sacrifice
it's implied that the coven tried the
ritual before with the dancer Patricia
played by Chloe Grace Moretz but
something about the ceremony went wrong
leaving Marcos near death and Patricia's
whereabouts unknown when audiences first
meet Susie Banyan played by Dakota
Johnson she evokes a lot of sympathy her
sheltered upbringing and self-taught
dance talents served to make her a
protagonist we can root for and we spend
most of the movie scared about what's
going to happen to her The Witches of
the coven clearly regard her as a
sacrifice in the making all but licking
their teeth at the idea of offering her
up as part of some deadly ritual of
course by the time we get to the end of
the movie well joke's on them right come
to find out Susie is actually a reborn
ancient Witch by the name of mother
suspiram one of the oldest witches in
existence who was Central to the
founding of the occult company as
Susie's staunchly religious birth mother
later claims on her deathbed Susie is
not a daughter that she loves but
instead her greatest sin it's a
devastatingly mean thing to say about
one's child but she's also kind of right
by the end of the movie Susie is no babe
in the woods but instead a force of
ageless power who is finally returning
to life to lead a league of witches even
if she's not in entirely aware of her
identity when the movie begins or
Patricia resisted the coven Susie
Embraces it going from a newcomer to a
leader in the company with remarkable
speed but the mystery of what happened
to Susie's predecessor looms over the
academy with Patricia's disappearance
being investigated by fellow students
Sarah as the movie revs up towards a
bloody climax minutes before a public
dance performance Sarah discovers that
Patricia didn't disappear from the
academy at all instead she's trapped
inside it somehow still alive along with
other victims of the witches including
Olga the woman who was literally torn
apart by Susie's dancing while the
victims are all still alive their bodies
are rotted and mangled thanks to some
witchcraft they are trapped in a state
of deathless suffering a devastating
fate which soon befalls Sarah as well
the innocent dancers of the Marcus
company are the only people being
manipulated into involvement in the
witch's ritual they also Target Dr
Joseph clemperer plotting to bring him
into their rebirth ritual as an
unwilling witness as we learned
throughout the movie The somber
therapist is haunted by The
Disappearance of his wife ankur who
vanished during World War II clemperer
has spent decades trying to move on from
this traumatic separation which makes it
all the more shocking when she appears
to him seemingly back from the dead at
his country home outside of Berlin in an
intriguing twist she's played by actress
Jessica Harper who played the role of
Susie in the original Suspiria their
reunion is so emotional that you almost
didn't notice that ankur is walking
Klemperer from the countryside back into
West Berlin right up to the doors of the
Marcus Academy as clemperer realizes
where his wife has led him she is
suddenly revealed to be a cruel illusion
of the witches leading him into a trap
in the movie's final act the characters
all descend on a hidden chamber inside
the academy where the rebirthing ritual
for mother Marcus is set to take place
the company's students are there in a
trance dancing and forming a sort of
human altar with their bodies klemper is
there among the witches as a captive
witness and so is the guest of honor
mother Marcos herself who appears in all
her hideous glory for the first time
since her last attempt at reincarnation
Marcos has been described as being on
death's door now we can see why it looks
as though she has become partially fused
with another body with extra malformed
limbs jutting impossibly from bulbous
form but soon it seems that she will be
reborn in a new body Susie's as Susie
enters a room to begin the ritual Marcos
and her allies believe the time for
reincarnation has finally arrived but
while Susie is all confident Blanc is an
easy scared even something feels wrong
to her Susie isn't acting like the
sheltered girl we thought we knew she's
acting more like she runs a place
putting Blanc on edge Blanc tries to
stop the ritual but fails when Marcos
attacks her nearly decapitating her with
telepathic magic spraying blood
everywhere
with Blanc sidelined it seems like
marcos's Resurrection is imminent but it
turns out that the ceremony isn't for
her rebirth at all instead the ritual is
a combination of a power play from an
even stronger witch that's been brewing
in the background the whole film tearing
her flesh open Susie reveals herself to
be none other than the revived mother
superiorum the Millennia old entity who
was a founding member of The Witches
occult order Susie or now suspirioreum
begins to unleash bloody hella Marcos
and their allies in the coven who dare
to seize power in her place she doesn't
do it alone instead she summons a living
embodiment of death itself the stroll
around the room making your enemies
heads explode it's pretty trippy after
Marcos and her followers are dispatched
the rest of the movie is essentially
Susie's Victory lap she spares the lives
of the dancers as well as the witches
who weren't loyal to Mother Marcus and
also allows Patricia Sarah and Olga to
finally die their ruined bodies
collapsing to the ground at an act of
motherly Mercy it's a completely
different take on the original Suspiria
story and if the movie's cryptic
post-credits scene is to be believed the
story might just be getting started the
original Suspiria directed by Dario
Argento had two sequels Inferno and the
mother of Tears each focusing on a
different one of the powerful witches
known as the three mothers is it
possible that the Remake director Luca
guardanino is explicitly teasing sequels
in the vein of argento's follow-ups
while nothing's been announced yet it is
possible but don't worry too much about
decoding that cryptic last shot
according to screenwriter David kaganich
the brief scene of Susie standing in the
cold making vague gestures wasn't even
scripted most likely the scene is just
open to interpretation and meant to send
the viewers out of the theater thinking
talking and weighing the ending's
implications with a heavy sigh